I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hey there! Happy New Year! Happy New Year! Happy New Guy! Offs ladies. Hello!
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。你好！嘿！新年快乐！新年快乐！新年快乐！办公室女士。你好！
Hey there! Happy new year! Happy new year! Happy new guys! Happy new season! All of the new stuff! This is exciting! It is!
嘿！新年快乐！新年快乐！新年快乐！新的一季！所有新鲜事！这太令人兴奋了！确实如此！
Also, happy new projects to us. Yeah! We both have some exciting new projects. I have the Mean Girls movie. It's coming out on January 12th. I cannot wait to see it. I cannot wait to see it. I have not seen it yet. So I'm going to be seeing it in the theaters with everybody else. Angela, I had such a fun time making this movie. I have a small role. I play Ms. Heron. You know, the lead girl is Katie Heron. She was originally played by Lindsay Lowen in the first movie and this movie she's played by and Gowri Rice. When I got the email about this movie, Tina Fey wrote me an email.
还有，祝我们有新的项目。耶！我们俩都有一些令人兴奋的新项目。我有《贱女孩》电影。它将于1月12日上映。我迫不及待想看了。我迫不及待想看了。我还没看过。所以我打算和大家一起在电影院看。安吉拉，制作这部电影我玩得很开心。我有一个小角色。我扮演赫伦女士。你知道，女主角是凯蒂·赫伦。她在第一部电影中由琳赛·洛翰饰演，而这部电影由安格瑞·赖斯饰演。当我收到关于这部电影的邮件时，蒂娜·菲给我写了一封邮件。
If Tina Fey emailed me, I would print it out and probably, I don't know, I definitely put it in my journal. I about pooped my pants. First of all, I didn't know Tina had my email. Yeah, she has her ways, I guess. So I get this email from Tina Fey and it's like, Jenna, we're doing a Mean Girls movie for a new generation and I would love for you to play the role of Ms. Heron. And I'm thinking to myself, I've been a little bit out of the acting game for a while. We've been happily podcasting. I thought why in the world would she even think of me for this part? I was so flattered. And then she said in her email, the person playing your daughter is Ann Gowry Rice. And she's a fantastic actress. So I Google her lady.
如果蒂娜·菲给我发邮件，我会把它打印出来，可能，我不知道，我肯定会把它放进我的日记里。我差点吓尿了。首先，我不知道蒂娜有我的邮箱。是的，我想她有她的办法。所以我收到了蒂娜·菲的这封邮件，内容是：珍娜，我们正在为新一代制作一部《贱女孩》电影，我很乐意让你扮演赫伦女士这个角色。我心想，我已经有一段时间没演戏了。我们一直在愉快地做播客。我想她为什么会想到让我演这个角色？我受宠若惊。然后在邮件里她说，扮演你女儿的人是安格瑞·赖斯。她是一位出色的演员。所以我谷歌了一下她，女士。
It immediately became clear to me why they thought of me to play her mother. She looks like it's Erie. It's Erie. We look the same. Literally, you could be related. She looks like my daughter, if my daughter grew up. Yes. I so believe it.
我立刻明白为什么他们想到让我演她的母亲了。她看起来太像了。太不可思议了。我们长得一模一样。真的，你们可能有亲戚关系。如果我女儿长大了，她看起来就像我女儿。是的。我完全相信。
I see it. I know. I was like, oh, well, now I know why they thought of me. Anyway, Tina sent me the script. And from the first five pages, I was like, I'm in. It was so funny, it was so good, it has musical numbers. My daughter and her friends cannot wait to see it. Well, my daughter and her friends are so excited
我看到了。我知道。我当时想，哦，好吧，现在我知道他们为什么想到我了。总之，蒂娜把剧本发给了我。从前五页开始，我就想，我加入。它太有趣了，太棒了，还有音乐片段。我女儿和她的朋友们迫不及待想看。好吧，我女儿和她的朋友们太兴奋了。
because the trailer for this first ran before the Taylor Swift movie. Oh, get out. And I guess they all say, you're cool now. I am. I am. This is what happened to me when I did Tall Girl. My daughter was like, oh, my friends saw you in a movie.
因为这部电影的预告片是在泰勒·斯威夫特的电影之前播放的。哦，别开玩笑了。我想她们都说，你现在很酷。我是。我是。这就是我拍《高个女孩》时发生在我身上的事。我女儿说，哦，我的朋友们在电影里看到你了。
Well, anyway, everybody please check it out. Mean Girls movie, January 12th. And, Angela, you have some big deal news, too. I do. I'm really excited. This is such a passion project for my husband and I for those of you that have been listening to the podcast you know, my husband's an amazing baker and a cook. We have done a little YouTube series called Baking with Josh and Ange, but let's
好吧，总之，请大家一定要去看看。《贱女孩》电影，1月12日。而且，安吉拉，你也有大新闻。我有。我真的很兴奋。这对我和我丈夫来说是一个充满激情的项目，对于那些一直收听播客的人来说，你们知道，我丈夫是一位出色的面包师和厨师。我们做了一个名为《与乔什和安吉一起烘焙》的小型YouTube系列，但让我们
be honest, he bakes and I just taste everything. I'm a little bit of a hot mess in the kitchen, but I've learned so much with him and the kitchen is really where our family came together. We're a blended family and it's the heart of our home and we're gonna do a cookbook. It's so cool. It's all of our favorite family recipes plus ones from our moms and our grandmothers and little stories and photos and I can't wait. I told Lee and he said, oh, that is just perfect. That is so perfect. And then he said, does she realize she's writing another book? Well, listen, Josh is doing all the recipes. And then I'm doing just like the little pops of stories, you know? Okay, I know. It's going to take two years who are we kidding? I'll be talking about this for a long time, but it is official.
诚实一点，他负责烘焙，我只是负责品尝一切。我在厨房里有点手忙脚乱，但我从他那里学到了很多，厨房确实是我们家庭凝聚在一起的地方。我们是一个重组家庭，它是我们家的核心，我们要出一本食谱。太酷了。里面有我们所有最喜欢的家庭食谱，还有来自我们母亲和祖母的食谱，以及一些小故事和照片，我等不及了。我告诉了李，他说，哦，那太完美了。那太完美了。然后他说，她意识到她又要写一本书了吗？好吧，听着，乔什负责所有的食谱。而我只是负责写一些小故事，你知道吗？好吧，我知道。这需要两年时间，我们在开什么玩笑？我会谈论这件事很长一段时间，但这是官方消息。
We're doing a cookbook. Yay! And then office ladies has really big news that we're not allowed to share it yet. I was gonna say, wait, we can't share that yet. But I'm so excited at the end of the month. At the end of this month of January, something very, very big is happening. Yes, and it's awesome and we can't wait for you to be a part of it. But we, very big is happening. Yes, and it's awesome, and we can't wait for you to be a part of it, but we can't say anything yet.
我们要出一本食谱。耶！然后“办公室女士”有一个非常大的新闻，我们还不能分享。我正想说，等等，我们还不能分享那个。但我太兴奋了，在月底。在这个一月的月底，一件非常非常大的事情要发生了。是的，这太棒了，我们迫不及待地想让你参与其中。但是我们，非常大的事情要发生了。是的，这太棒了，我们迫不及待地想让你参与其中，但我们还不能说任何事情。
We can't say anything yet. Okay. All right, well, let's jump into this episode. It is new guys. It is season nine, episode one. Season nine, let that sit in. I know. We're here.
我们还不能说任何事情。好吧。好吧，让我们进入这一集。这是新的一季。这是第九季，第一集。第九季，让这个事实沉淀一下。我知道。我们到了。
Sink in? Are you gonna sit it in? I'm gonna sit it in. Okay. I am not gonna sink in to any, I'm sitting in. Sit it into it Are you going to sit it in? I'm going to sit it in. Okay. I am not going to sink into any I'm sitting in. Sit in. Let's sit into it. Let that. Anyway, you know what I'm saying. Okay. This was written by Greg Daniels, directed by Greg Daniels, and here is your summary. This Grant and Branch underwent many changes over the summer. We're going to get updates. We have said goodbye to a few employees and we're welcoming some new ones. Also
沉淀一下？你要沉淀一下吗？我要沉淀一下。好吧。我不会沉淀到任何地方，我正在沉淀。沉淀进去，你要沉淀进去吗？我要沉淀进去。好吧。我不会沉淀到任何地方，我正在沉淀。沉淀。让我们沉淀进去。让那个。总之，你知道我在说什么。好吧。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导，这是你的摘要。邓德米夫林分公司在夏天经历了许多变化。我们将获得更新。我们已经告别了一些员工，并欢迎了一些新员工。此外，
in this episode, Andy returns from Outward Bound as a terrible person who bullies Nelly. He went to Outward Bound to become like a dickhead. I don't understand what happened. It's the worst advertising for Outward Bound and Outward Bound. I'm sorry, Outward Bound. It's true of advertising for Outward Bound. I'm sorry, Outward Bound. It's true of advertising. Oh my gosh. Also, Angela needs to re-home her cat. Yes, Comstock.
在这一集中，安迪从“外展训练”回来，变成了一个欺负内莉的糟糕透顶的人。他去参加“外展训练”是为了变成一个混蛋。我不明白发生了什么。这是对“外展训练”最糟糕的广告，外展训练。对不起，外展训练。这是对“外展训练”的真实广告。天哪。此外，安吉拉需要为她的猫找个新家。是的，康斯托克。
Mm-hmm. Jim is going to do some soul searching. And Dwight has found himself a new rival in Dwight Jr. Dwight Jr. who apparently is a slackline, aficionado. Yeah, who knew? Who knew? Fast- Fast fact number one, Greg Daniels is back. He's come home. That's right. Like I said before, this episode was both written by and directed by Greg. It is the first episode of the office that he has written since goodbye Michael in season 7.
嗯哼。吉姆要进行一些灵魂探索。而德怀特发现自己有了一个新对手，德怀特二世。德怀特二世，他显然是一个走钢丝爱好者。是的，谁知道呢？谁知道呢？快讯第一条，格雷格·丹尼尔斯回来了。他回家了。没错。就像我之前说的，这一集既是由格雷格编剧的，也是由他执导的。这是自第七季《再见迈克尔》以来，他编剧的第一集《办公室》。
since goodbye Michael in season seven. Hmm. Yeah, so it's been a while. And he is also back as our showrunner for the whole season. We were so excited. Greg gave an interview to Variety where he talked a little bit about his vision for this season. First of all, he said,
自第七季《再见迈克尔》以来。嗯。是的，所以已经有一段时间了。他也是我们整个赛季的剧集主管。我们太兴奋了。格雷格接受了《综艺》杂志的采访，谈到了他对这一季的一些愿景。首先，他说，
we will not be telling the story of who is in the manager's chair. Who is manager is no longer a story. Thank the Lord. You know what? I was done with that. Me too. Not that anyone asked. I think we were all done with it. Yeah. Greg said instead he hoped to focus on big arcs in relationships.
我们不会讲述谁坐在经理椅子上的故事。谁是经理不再是一个故事了。感谢上帝。你知道吗？我受够了。我也是。并不是有人问我。我想我们都受够了。是的。格雷格说，相反，他希望专注于人际关系中的大弧线。
He also wanted to write stories where different characters were the lead of each episode. And you're gonna really see that in season nine. Each of our characters is gonna have a real nice A story. Yeah. Greg also announced that all of the questions about who was behind the documentary would be answered this year.
他还想写一些故事，让不同的角色成为每一集的主角。你真的会在第九季中看到这一点。我们的每一个角色都会有一个非常好的A故事。是的。格雷格还宣布，关于谁是纪录片幕后黑手的所有问题都将在今年得到解答。
Ta-da-da. So something I think everyone should know is that when we started shooting this episode, we did not know that season 9 would be the last season of the office. They did not tell us that until we were shooting work bus. We talked about this on our book, The Office BFFs.
哒哒哒。所以我想每个人都应该知道的一件事是，当我们开始拍摄这一集时，我们并不知道第九季会是《办公室》的最后一季。直到我们拍摄《工作巴士》时，他们才告诉我们。我们在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》中谈到了这一点。
That would be the first book I've written. It's right second book. Yeah, we didn't know yet. Yeah, but by the time this episode aired, we did know. So when it premiered, there was a lot of press about this being our last season. But at this point, what we knew was that rain had only signed up to do 13 episodes of season nine
那是我写的第一本书。这是第二本书。是的，我们还不知道。是的，但当这一集播出时，我们确实知道了。所以当它首播时，有很多关于这是我们最后一季的报道。但在这一点上，我们所知道的是，雷恩只签了第九季的13集，
because he and Paul Lieberstein were branching out and developing a spin-off of the office called the Farm, featuring Dwight. Yes, and this is why Paul stepped down a showrunner and Greg stepped back in. The idea was that Rain Wilson would do a half season of the office, and then the Farm would come out in January, and then Rain would leave the office, do the Farm, and the the farm would come out in January, and then rain would leave the office, do the farm, and the two shows would overlap. Another thing that we knew was that Ed Helms only signed up to do a half a year, because he was going to leave in the middle to shoot the hangover three.
因为他和保罗·利伯斯坦正在拓展业务，开发一部名为《农场》的《办公室》衍生剧，以德怀特为主角。是的，这就是为什么保罗辞去了剧集主管的职务，而格雷格又重新接手的原因。当时的想法是，雷恩·威尔逊将拍摄半季的《办公室》，然后《农场》会在一月份播出，然后雷恩会离开《办公室》，去拍《农场》，两部剧会重叠。我们知道的另一件事是，艾德·赫尔姆斯只签了半年的合同，因为他要在中间离开去拍摄《宿醉3》。
So we knew we would have Ed for a few episodes at the beginning, and then a few at the end. So the only sort of two like quote unquote lead characters that were left were me and John. And John wanted to do one more full year, but it kind of seemed like after that, we weren't sure if he was gonna be up for a season 10. And I wasn't really sure how Pam was gonna stay on the office without Jim.
所以我们知道在开始时会有艾德，然后在最后会有几集。所以剩下的两个所谓的“主角”只有我和约翰。约翰想再拍完整的一年，但看起来在那之后，我们不确定他是否会愿意拍第十季。而且我真的不确定没有吉姆，帕姆该如何留在《办公室》。
I was open to hearing options, but it did kind of seem like this was going to be Jim and Pam's last year altogether. Yes, it's under Mifflin. Yes. So as a result, they asked John and I to come on this season as producers so that we could help direct the Jim and Pam's storyline since it was going to be our last full year together on the show. And I have to applaud my BFF because all of a sudden, this meant that you were gonna have information that you couldn't share right away with me
我愿意听取意见，但看起来这确实会是吉姆和帕姆在一起的最后一年。是的，在邓德米夫林。是的。因此，他们要求约翰和我以制片人的身份加入这一季，这样我们就可以帮助指导吉姆和帕姆的故事情节，因为这将是我们在一起的最后一个完整的一年。我必须为我的闺蜜鼓掌，因为这意味着你突然有了不能立刻和我分享的信息，
because you were now our producer. You were very professional. You never spilled the beans on anything, even though I'm sure you wanted to. So, professional BFF. Thank you very much. It was actually very difficult. I know it was. And I tried not to bug you very much. It was actually very difficult. I know it was.
因为你现在是我们的制片人。你非常专业。你从来没有泄露过任何事情，尽管我相信你想这样做。所以，专业的闺蜜。非常感谢。这实际上非常困难。我知道。我尽量不去打扰你。这实际上非常困难。我知道。
And I tried not to bug you because I knew it was hard and I appreciate that Angela. Well like I said by the time the season was ready to premiere we all knew it would be our last season and we did tons of press and interviews about it. You can see all of them on officetelly.com. Angela we are all so emotional. I know I watched a few. We're all very weepy. Phyllis is like choking back tears. The entire time she's being interviewed. And I feel like if you want to truly understand how emotional we all were, you just have to listen
我尽量不去打扰你，因为我知道这很难，我很感激，安吉拉。好吧，就像我说的，当这一季准备首播时，我们都知道这将是我们的最后一季，我们为此做了大量的媒体采访。你可以在officetelly.com上看到所有这些。安吉拉，我们都太情绪化了。我知道，我看了几个。我们都非常爱哭。菲利斯在接受采访时一直在强忍泪水。我觉得如果你想真正了解我们当时有多情绪化，你只需要听听
to Creed's interview because he does not make a single joke in the interview. Yeah. He's totally serious. I have the audio clip. But hear it. Yeah. I think we want to go out with a bang and raise our game and walk out of here feeling like we've, well, we already feel like we've been on a winning show
克里德的采访，因为他在采访中没有开一个玩笑。是的。他非常严肃。我有音频片段。但听听看。是的。我想我们想以轰动的方式结束，提高我们的水平，离开这里时感觉我们已经，好吧，我们已经觉得我们参加了一个成功的节目，
and we've left a mark. But obviously you want to take it up, take up the, take the bar, raise the bar a little bit higher. So I think we're all pulling together as a team and nothing we always haven't. But yeah, it's kind of, I wouldn't say I'm not modeling about it, but it's been, it's this family, you know, it's gonna be sad leaving these people.
并且我们留下了印记。但显然你想提高，提高标准，把标准提高一点。所以我认为我们都在作为一个团队共同努力，并不是说我们以前没有这样做过。但是的，这有点，我不会说我对此很伤感，但这，这是这个家庭，你知道，离开这些人会很难过。
Right. Oh yeah. Right. Because Creed normally cuts stuff with a joke, you know? But that was just so honest. And yeah. Yeah. Right. Because Creed normally cuts stuff with a joke, you know? But that was just so honest and yeah. Yeah. And I felt like it kind of summed up perfectly how we felt about it. Yeah.
对。哦，是的。对。因为克里德通常会用笑话来结束事情，你知道吗？但这太诚实了。是的。是的。对。因为克里德通常会用笑话来结束事情，你知道吗？但这太诚实了，是的。是的。我觉得这完美地总结了我们的感受。是的。
Mm-hmm. Are you ready for FastFact number two? I am. I'm just like, oh my gosh, am I going to be weeping this whole last season nine? Maybe. Maybe. Okay. Well, FastFact number two is all about finding our new guys. Clark and Pete. Yes, our plop in Drake Jr. who could have been called fart. But no,
嗯哼。你准备好听快讯第二条了吗？我准备好了。我只是想，天哪，我会在整个最后一季第九季中一直哭吗？也许吧。也许吧。好吧，快讯第二条是关于寻找我们的新成员。克拉克和皮特。是的，我们的普洛普和德怀特二世，本来可以叫“屁”。但没有，
went another way. Went another way. Well, we got a lot of fan mail. Cory Kay from Illinois said, please tell us everything about the actors who played Clark and Plop, love these two additions to the office, and Jamie D. from Atlanta, Georgia said, I love the addition of Clark and Plop, especially Clark, who is in my top three favorite office characters, and I want to know everything about how he came to be, give me the deets, please, and thank you. Well, I reached out to our casting director, Alison Jones, to find out what exactly happened. How did we find these guys? Alison said this was an extensive search.
换了另一种方式。换了另一种方式。好吧，我们收到了很多粉丝来信。来自伊利诺伊州的科里·凯说，请告诉我们关于扮演克拉克和普洛普的演员的一切，喜欢这两个加入《办公室》的新成员，来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的杰米·D说，我喜欢克拉克和普洛普的加入，尤其是克拉克，他在我最喜欢的《办公室》角色前三名中，我想知道关于他如何加入的一切，请给我细节，谢谢。好吧，我联系了我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯，想弄清楚到底发生了什么。我们是怎么找到这些人的？艾莉森说这是一次广泛的搜索。
She said not since she had to cast the role of Karen. Has she auditioned so many people for a role in the office? I bet two new people coming in at this stage in the show. She said she auditioned stage in the show. She said she auditioned people in New York. She auditioned people in Los Angeles. One of the reasons that they searched so intensely to cast these two actors was because at this point, there was an idea that the office would continue
她说自从她必须为凯伦这个角色选角以来，她还没有为《办公室》的一个角色试镜过这么多人。我敢打赌，在这个阶段有两个新成员加入。她说她在纽约试镜了人。她在洛杉矶试镜了人。他们如此努力地寻找这两位演员的原因之一是，当时有一个想法，即《办公室》会继续
into season 10. Even if some of the regular cast members moved on, the idea was that these two new people were going to move us in to the next generation of the office. Clark Duke did an interview where he said, when Jake and I joined the show, the idea was that this was going to be a show like ER, where new leads could move in and out and it might run for like 20 years.
拍到第十季。即使一些常规演员离开了，想法也是这两个新成员将带领我们进入《办公室》的下一代。克拉克·杜克在接受采访时说，当杰克和我加入剧组时，想法是这将是一部像《急诊室的故事》那样的剧，新的主角可以进进出出，可能会拍20年。
So that was the vision. Allison wasn't just casting like guest stars or recurring characters. She was casting the next phase of the office. The comedy ER. Yes, it's 20 years. And Dundermifflin. Just rotating people through this paper company.
所以这就是愿景。艾莉森不仅仅是在选客串明星或常驻角色。她是在选《办公室》的下一阶段。喜剧版的《急诊室的故事》。是的，20年。在邓德米夫林。只是让人们在这家造纸公司轮换。
That's right. The most successful small paper company with a documentary that never ends. Well, Alison knew Clark Duke, who was cast as Clark. He was cast first. He had done a show called Clark and Michael starring himself and Michael Sarah. He was also in hot tub time machine with Craig Robinson
没错。最成功的造纸小公司，还有一部永无止境的纪录片。好吧，艾莉森认识克拉克·杜克，他被选为克拉克。他是第一个被选中的。他曾制作过一部名为《克拉克和迈克尔》的剧，由他和迈克尔·塞拉主演。他还和克雷格·罗宾逊一起出演了《热浴盆时光机》，
and kickass. He was sort of in that Judd Apto comedy circle. Alice in thinks that he did not even audition that they offered him the role. So they got that done first. And I found an audio clip of Clark talking about joining the show. Would you like to hear it? Yes. I was really flattered when they when they approached me about it. I'm a big fan of the show and have been since it started, I guess, nine years ago, and the British one before that. So I was very excited, thrilled to be a part of it. My character is also named Clark, which is convenient, because it's easy to remember, you know, on the call sheet too. You know, without giving it too much away, but there's really not like any big secrets.
还有《海扁王》。他算是贾德·阿帕图喜剧圈的人。艾莉森认为他甚至没有试镜，他们直接给了他这个角色。所以他们先完成了这件事。我找到了克拉克谈论加入剧组的音频片段。你想听听吗？是的。当他们联系我时，我真的受宠若惊。我是这部剧的忠实粉丝，从它开始，我想是九年前，以及之前的英国版。所以我非常兴奋，很高兴能成为其中的一员。我的角色也叫克拉克，这很方便，因为在通告单上也容易记住，你知道。在不剧透太多的情况下，真的没有什么大秘密。
My guy is just sort of a new guy that works at the office. He's not like a secret agent or anything. It's infiltrated the office. So there you go. Well, I have two things to share about Clark and Jake. Mm-hmm. So since you're talking about Clark, we got into this conversation one day on set because
我的角色只是一个在办公室工作的新人。他不是什么特工之类的。渗透了办公室。所以就是这样。好吧，关于克拉克和杰克，我有两件事要分享。嗯哼。既然你在谈论克拉克，有一天我们在片场进行了这样的对话，因为
His last name is Duke and my mom's maiden name is Duke and I was like Clark. What if we're related? And so then we started trying to figure it out and he talked to his mom and I talked to my mom and we're like my mom I was like well, we did have some family that moved around and so we sort of joked that we were maybe distant cousins. But you never found out for sure. We never found out for sure. But I did start sending his family my Christmas card. Just in case. Just in case.
他的姓是杜克，我妈妈的娘家姓也是杜克，我就说克拉克。如果我们有亲戚关系怎么办？于是我们开始试图弄清楚，他和他妈妈谈过，我也和我妈妈谈过，我们就像，我妈妈说，好吧，我们确实有一些搬迁的亲戚，所以我们开玩笑说我们可能是远房表亲。但你从来没有确定过。我们从来没有确定过。但我确实开始给他的家人寄我的圣诞贺卡。以防万一。以防万一。
And his mom would send me their Christmas card. That is the sweetest thing. I just love that. Well, let's move on to Jake Lacey now, who got the role of Pete. Alison said that they read a couple hundred people for the role of Pete. And eventually they settled on a handful of people. They flew Jake in from New York to meet with Greg. And Jake did not have a lot of TV credits when he got the role in the office.
他妈妈也会给我寄他们的圣诞贺卡。这是最甜蜜的事情。我真的很喜欢。好吧，现在让我们谈谈杰克·莱西，他得到了皮特的角色。艾莉森说他们为皮特这个角色读了几百人的剧本。最终他们确定了几个人。他们让杰克从纽约飞过来见格雷格。杰克在得到《办公室》的角色时并没有太多的电视作品。
He basically just killed it in his audition. That is how he got the role. By the way, not having a lot of TV credits with Greg doesn't mean anything. No. That was the wonderful thing about all of us getting cast on the office. He was like, I don't care about your experience. Are you great? Yeah.
他基本上在试镜中表现得非常出色。这就是他得到角色的方式。顺便说一句，没有太多的电视作品对格雷格来说并不意味着什么。不。这就是我们所有人被选中出演《办公室》的美妙之处。他说，我不关心你的经验。你很棒吗？是的。
Done. You get the job. Jake did an interview at the start of the season where he said he had started watching the office when he was in college and he was a huge fan of the show. And I remember this, Angela. I remember talking about this and made me feel very old on set, but here's the audio clip. Yeah, this was definitely my dream job.
完成了。你得到了这份工作。杰克在这一季开始时接受了采访，他说他上大学时就开始看《办公室》了，他是这部剧的忠实粉丝。我记得这个，安吉拉。我记得谈论过这个，这让我觉得在片场很老，但这是音频片段。是的，这绝对是我的梦想工作。
I think, you know, three months ago, if you had said, there's any show you pick it, you can be on it. I would have said the office. And I was just blown away when this opportunity came up and then to get out here and test for it and think like, wow, it's getting close, you know? And then to find out that I got it was thrilling, absolutely thrilling. I mean, yeah, they were so young.
我想，你知道，三个月前，如果你说，有任何节目你可以选，你可以参加。我会说《办公室》。当这个机会出现时，我感到非常震惊，然后来到这里试镜，心想，哇，越来越近了，你知道吗？然后发现我得到了它，这太令人兴奋了，绝对令人兴奋。我的意思是，是的，他们太年轻了。
We were dinosaurs. I remember feeling very old around them. Me too. I loved them. I young. We were dinosaurs. I remember feeling very old around them. Me too. I loved them. I know. They were wonderful. And you know what? They were this really fun new energy. They were the new guys. They were. It was great having them around. Here's my little thing about Jake Lacey. I was walking down the hallway to the set. We had this sort of area behind the set. We've talked about where hair and makeup was. And you would walk down this little corridor and then all of a sudden you were in the bullpen of Dundrumifland. And I'm walking down this
我们是恐龙。我记得在他们身边感觉自己很老。我也是。我爱他们。我年轻。我们是恐龙。我记得在他们身边感觉自己很老。我也是。我爱他们。我知道。他们很棒。你知道吗？他们是一种非常有趣的新能量。他们是新人。他们是。有他们在身边真是太好了。这是关于杰克·莱西的小事。我正走在去片场的走廊上。我们在片场后面有这样一个区域。我们谈论过发型和化妆在哪里。你会走过这条小走廊，然后突然你就到了邓德米夫林的办公区。我正走在这条
corridor and I hear this voice behind me talking to someone and I thought, oh, Jenna's husband Lee is on set today. And I turned I literally I think I said Lee as I turned around. I think I was like Lee and it was Jake. I thought he sounded so similar to your husband. His voice is the cadence, something about it is so similar that it would just throw me off. The first big conference room scenes we would have, I feel like I keep thinking Lee is here. That's so funny.
走廊上，我听到身后有人在和某人说话，我想，哦，珍娜的丈夫李今天在片场。我转过身，我真的，我想我在转身时说了“李”。我想我当时说的是“李”，结果是杰克。我觉得他的声音听起来和你丈夫太像了。他的声音，节奏，某种程度上非常相似，以至于让我感到困惑。我们进行的第一次大型会议室场景，我觉得我一直以为李在这里。太有趣了。
I remember you telling me that and I hear it. I can hear it. Well, we will have more stories about these guys and obviously we're going to ask them to come on office. Yes. Jake and Clark, you have to come on. Now fast fact number three is a fan question from Elsa S. In Minnesota, who asked, this episode is the first time we see a big shift in Andy's personality that continues for the rest of season nine. Elsa. Oh my gosh. Elsa, I have so many thoughts on this. I'm so glad you wrote
我记得你告诉过我，我听到了。我能听出来。好吧，我们会有更多关于这些家伙的故事，显然我们会邀请他们来“办公室”。是的。杰克和克拉克，你们一定要来。现在快讯第三条是来自明尼苏达州埃尔莎·S的粉丝提问，她问，这一集是我们第一次看到安迪个性的重大转变，这种转变一直持续到第九季的其余部分。埃尔莎。天哪。埃尔莎，我对此有很多想法。我很高兴你写信
in. Sorry, Jenna. I interrupted you. Go on. No, no. Elsa went on to say he has always had flaws, but generally been a likable guy until now. Do you have any insights into why the writers chose to make this change. Well, clearly from what you shared, he was going to be leaving the show, but my thought is, like, I imagine this writer's remeting, which I know didn't happen where they're like, how do we just burn Andy to the ground? How do we make him so horrible? Well, I traded emails with Greg Daniels about this episode.
进来。对不起，珍娜。我打断你了。继续。不，不。埃尔莎接着说，他一直有缺点，但直到现在通常是一个讨人喜欢的家伙。你对编剧为什么选择做出这种改变有什么见解吗？好吧，显然从你分享的内容来看，他要离开剧组了，但我的想法是，我想象这个编剧会议，我知道并没有发生，他们就像，我们如何彻底摧毁安迪？我们如何让他变得如此可怕？好吧，我就这一集与格雷格·丹尼尔斯交换了电子邮件。
And he said, yes, they knew that Ed was going to be missing for a big chunk of episodes in the middle of the season, and they had to write toward that. They had to come up with a reason why he was going to disappear. So that kind of started from there, and they worked backwards. But in the writer's room, they talked about who is Andy. And Greg said he was originally a guy with anger management issues, who put his fist through a wall.
他说，是的，他们知道艾德在这一季中间会有很大一部分剧集缺席，他们必须为此进行创作。他们必须想出一个他会消失的理由。所以这从那里开始，他们倒推着写。但在编剧室里，他们谈论了安迪是谁。格雷格说他最初是一个有愤怒管理问题的人，曾一拳打穿墙壁。
And over in Stanford, he had been introduced as kind of like an antagonistic, Dwight-like annoying deskmate for Jim. And they wanted to bring back some of the old qualities of the character. They said they actually feel like the Andy we're seeing in season nine is a truer extension of where Andy started than the softer character that we've been seeing
而在斯坦福，他被介绍为一个像德怀特一样令人讨厌的吉姆的办公桌邻居。他们想带回这个角色的一些旧品质。他们说他们实际上觉得我们在第九季中看到的安迪，比我们在过去一季中看到的那个更柔和的角色，是安迪最初形象的更真实的延伸。他说，你知道，安迪不是为了成为剧集的主角而设计的。他被设计成一种调味品。他们想把那种味道带回剧中。格雷格还说，这个版本的安迪更有能力做出愚蠢的行为。愚蠢，愚蠢，愚蠢，愚蠢。
for the last season. He said, you know, Andy wasn't designed to be the lead of a show. He was designed to be a flavor. And they wanted to bring that flavor back to the show. Greg also said that this version of Andy was more capable of foolishness. F foolishness,ness foolishness foolishness foolishness foolishness.
我不知道那是终极的愚蠢。如果你是愚蠢，终极，它是终极的。最后，格雷格说，安迪角色的这种改变也将有助于服务于他的愿景，即以吉姆、帕姆、德怀特和安吉拉为核心角色，并追踪他们的人际关系。好吧，安吉拉，这就是我所有的内容。今天节目开头很长。是的，你有很多东西。我都很喜欢。新的一季。新的一年。是的。好吧，我有相当多
I don't know that's ultimate foolishness. If you're foolishness,ness ultimate, it's ultimate. Finally, Greg said that this change in Andy's character was also going to help kind of serve his vision, which was to center the season around Jim and Pam and Dwight and Angela as our core characters and follow their relationships through. Well, Angela, that's all I got. That was a long top of show today. Yeah, you had a lot of stuff. I loved it all. A new season. It's a new year. Yes. Well, I have quite a new season. It's a new year. Yes
关于这一集的内容来自我的数字杂物。我有通告单，哦，但我们为什么不休息一下呢，因为当我们回来时，我们会进入这一集。关于艾琳的新发型，我有很多问题。哦，先从这里开始。好吧。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 好吧，我们回来了。艾琳在工作。她非常兴奋，因为安迪今天回来了。安迪今天回来了。嗯哼。内莉没那么兴奋。
Well, I have quite a bit for this episode from my digital clutter. I have call sheets Ooh, but why don't we take a break because when we come back we'll get into this episode I have a lot of questions about Aaron's new hairdo. Oh to kick things off. Okay. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Well, we are back. Erin is at work. She's very excited because Andy's coming back today. Andy's coming back today. Mm-hmm. Nelly's not so excited.
为什么她很紧张？我的意思是，我不得不说，当我们浏览这一集的开头时，我有一些不太连贯的连续性问题。是的。我会提出来，第一个是，如果我们还不知道他是个彻头彻尾的混蛋，为什么内莉对安迪的回归感到紧张？
Why is she nervous? I mean, I'm gonna have to say that as we go through the very top of this episode, I have some continuity things that don't quite line up. Yeah. I'm gonna bring them up and the first one is, why is Nelly nervous about Andy's return if we don't know that he's a total jerk yet?
对。发生了什么事吗？在他离开之前我们没看到。我可能有一些来自拍摄草稿的内容可能会有帮助，但并不是真的。只是有一些连续性漏洞。是的。好吧，你知道，我说过我的数字杂物里有很多东西，我找到了这一集的通告单。它最初被称为“职场恶霸”。
Right. Did something happen? We didn't see before he left. I might have a few things from the shooting draft that might help, but not really. There's just some continuity holes. Yeah. Well, you know, I said I had a lot for my digital clutter, and I found a call sheet for this episode. It was originally called Workplace Bulley.
是的。没错。我当时正试图像妈妈侦探一样去发现什么。所以我联系了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我说，我能要这一集的所有通告单吗？这就是我试图像妈妈侦探一样去发现的，这也打开了通告单上的一大堆好东西。但这就是它的开始。我发现了一封我这周发给你的邮件，标题是“地震”。然后当你打开邮件时，它说，在我的拖车里，你感觉到那次地震了吗？你回信说，什么时候？问号。
Yes. Yep. And I was trying to mom detect if something. So I reached out to Steve Burgess and I said, can I have all of the call sheets for this episode? Here's what I was trying to mom detective, which then also just opened up a whole bunch of great stuff on the call sheets. But this is what it started with. I found an email that I sent to you this week titled Earthquake. And then when you opened the email, it said, in my trailer, did you feel that earthquake? And you wrote back, when? Question mark.
然后我就再也没回你。哦，好吧。这已经是一个真正的妈妈侦探了，对吧？就像我们有一件事，但我们不知道答案。所以我心想，也许它可能在通告单里的某个地方。他们会那样做。他们会写上天气。他们可能会说有地震。所以我看了这一周所有的通告单。没有提到地震。据我
And then I never responded to you. Oh, okay. This is a true mom detective already, right? It's like we have a thing and we don't know the answer. So I thought, maybe it might have been somewhere in the call sheets. They would do that. They would put the answer. So I thought maybe it might have been somewhere in the call sheets. They would do that. They would put the weather. They might say there was a earthquake. So I looked through all the week's call sheets. There is no mention of an earthquake. For all
所知，有一辆大卡车经过我的拖车。但我发现了一些有趣的事情可以分享。首先，艾琳说“安迪回来了，安迪回来了”这一幕，是拍摄的第一天。那是2012年7月30日，星期一。最高气温将达到95度。哇。整个星期实际上都在90多度。这一天的通告单上有一个特别说明，说“午餐后，德怀特、克拉克和内莉的走钢丝排练将在仓库的秋千区进行”。不。所以这是他们练习走钢丝的第一天。他们暑假后回到工作的第一天，就要以走钢丝练习开始。而且气温在90多度。哇。然后珍娜，当我查看通告单时，我看到了这个让我微笑的小东西。
I know there was a big truck driving by my trailer. But I found some fun things to share. First of all, this scene where Aaron saying, Andy's coming back, Andy's coming back, that was day one of filming. It was Monday, July 30, 2012. The high was going to be 95. Wow. The whole week it was actually in the 90s. And there was a special note on the call sheet for this day that said, slackline rehearsals with Dwight, Clark, and Nelly will take place in the swing set area of the warehouse after lunch today. No. So this was their first day to practice slacklining. Their first day back to work after the summer break and that's gonna kick off with some slackline practice. And it's in the 90s. Wow. And then Jenna, as I was looking over the call sheet, I saw this little thing that just made me smile.
我一说你就会记得。在通告单的背面，他们会做一个名为“了解你的演职人员”的小短文。基本上，他们会分享有趣的小花絮，每天介绍一个人。我太喜欢它们了。我很期待它们。所以我打算在其中穿插一些。但让我们进入这一集。好吧，我喜欢这个。我们会进行小新闻插播。我们会帮助你帮助我们了解我们的演职人员。我们会进行通告单新闻插播。哦，这是我希望成为第九季新元素的内容。哦，让我们做吧。获取所有的通告单。是的。好吧，下一步艾琳将有一个谈话头，她解释说大卫·华莱士送安迪去参加“外展训练”荒野冒险。
You'll remember it as soon as I say it. On the back of the call sheets, they would do a little blurb called Get to Know Your Casting Crew. And basically, they would share fun little tidbits and feature one person a day. I loved them so much. I would look forward to them. So I thought I'd sprinkle a few of those in. but let's get to this episode. Well, I love that. We'll have little news breaks. We'll help you help us get to know our cast and crew. We'll have call sheet news breaks. Oh, this is I hope going to be a new element here for season nine. Oh, let's do it. Get all the call sheets. Yes. Well, next step Aaron is going to have a talking head where she explains that David Wallace sent Andy on an outward bound wilderness adventure.
这应该有助于他的自信和果断。大卫·华莱士的儿子也去了。我想辅导员报告说，大卫·华莱士的儿子和安迪都“长大了，非常大”。安迪“长大了，非常大”。你知道，我们收到了来自马里兰州巴尔的摩市克洛伊·S的粉丝提问，她说，我是一名全职首席讲师。他们不叫辅导员，是巴尔的摩外展训练学校的教练。克洛伊说这一集每次都让我大笑。
It's supposed to help with his confidence and his decisiveness. David Wallace's son also went. And I guess the counselor reported back that both David Wallace's son and Andy, quote, grew up big time big time. Andy, quote, grew up big time, big time. You know, we got a fan question from Chloe S in Baltimore, Maryland, who said, I am a full time lead instructor. They're not called counselors and trainer at the Outward Bound School in Baltimore. Chloe said this episode makes me laugh out loud every time.
但克洛伊想让你们都知道，外展训练永远不会允许一个成年男人作为学生参加团队课程，所以这个概念让我觉得非常有趣。然而，当安迪带他的教练来上班并用他们的绰号称呼他们时，走钢丝并提到他的，我想在独处时经常想到这个地方。真的让我笑得流泪。克洛伊说关于这一集我还有很多话要说或补充。谢谢你们。克洛伊，绰号“捆绑”。谢谢捆绑。谢谢捆绑。我想知道你的绰号会是什么。哦，我不知道你的绰号是什么。零食。零食。
But Chloe would like you all to know that outward bound would never allow a grown man to join a team course as a student, so this concept tickles me greatly. However, when Andy brings his instructors to work and calls them by their trail names, does the slackline and mentions his, I thought about this place a lot while on solo. Just brings me to tears laughing. Chloe said there is so much I could say or add to this episode. Thank you all. Chloe, trail name, bundles. Thank you bundles. Thank you bundles. I wonder what your trail name would be. Oh, I don't know what's your trail name. Snacks. Snacks.
我是零食。你是自己选名字还是别人给你的？不，我相信是别人给你的。我们不知道。我们不知道。我们不知道。克洛伊，我在工作。我们的绰号是什么，克洛伊？
Mine's snacks. Do you get to pick your own name or just someone give it to you? No, I'm sure someone gives it to you. We don't know. We don't know. We don't know. Chloe, I was at work. What are our trail names, Chloe?
好吧，德怀特现在要来上班了。这对我来说太有趣了，每个人都在谈论他们的夏天。珍娜，你和我进行了一次侧边对话，我们说，我想纪录片摄制组夏天休息。每年，他们夏天都休息。这恰好也与我们的休假时间重合。
Well, Dwight is now going to arrive to work. This is so interesting to me that everyone is talking about their summer. Jenna, you and I had a sidebar conversation where we're like, I guess the documentary crew takes off for the summer. Every year, they take off for the summer. It just happened to coincide with our hiatus as well.
是的。所以德怀特说，你知道吗？在夏天，他用甜菜径流创造了一种新的能量饮料。太好喝了。它是亮蓝色的。对我来说看起来像蓝色覆盆子佳得乐。他说他还得到了一些令人失望的医疗消息。
Yeah. So Dwight says, you know what? During his summer, he created a new energy drink made from beet runoff. It's so good. It's bright blue. It looks like the blue raspberry gatorade to me. And he said he also got some disappointing medical news.
是的。在我们谈到那个之前，我只想让你知道，我今天想为我们做某种甜菜径流饮料，因为我确实做了甜菜伏特加，但你没有。我没有，因为我查了一下，我不认为你可以喝它。事实上，我发现关于甜菜径流唯一能做的事情，如果我错了，有人可以纠正我，是我发现他们把它用作道路盐的替代品。这是真的。我们可以在恶劣天气下。我想多年来，工程师们一直在寻找道路盐的替代品，这
Yeah. Before we get to that, I just want you to know, I thought about making some kind of beet runoff drink for us today because I did make beat vodka, but you didn't. I didn't because I looked it up and I don't think you can drink it. And in fact the only thing I found that you can do with beat runoff, someone can correct me if I'm wrong, is I found that they're using it as an alternative to road salt. It's true. We can bad weather. I guess for years, engineers have been trying to find alternatives to road salt, which
可以减少对环境和基础设施的破坏。它对混凝土非常有害。所以他们开始使用这种甜菜汁径流。是的。听起来你不应该把它放进身体里，对吧？好吧，它说它能够像盐一样引起冰晶的破坏。你知道，那篇文章非常有趣。我会放一个链接，但有一个评论区。好吧。有一个评论让我大笑。辛迪写道，使用甜菜汁的另一个缺点是气味。
can cause less damage to the environment and to our infrastructure. It's very bad for concrete. So they've started using this type of beet juice runoff. Yeah. It doesn't sound like you should put it in your body then, right? Well, it says that it's capable of causing a disruption in ice crystals much like salt. You know, the article was very interesting. I'll put a link to it, but there was a comment section. Okay. There was a comment that made me laugh out loud. Cindy wrote in to say, one other downside to using beet juice is the odor.
在我所在的马萨诸塞州列克星敦镇，它施用后闻起来像死鱼。哦，所以你知道，我想甜菜汁径流还是有一些用途的。好吧，是的。我不认为你应该喝它。好吧，如果下一幕有什么迹象表明你应该喝它。好吧，如果下一幕有什么迹象表明你应该喝它，
In my town of Lexington, Massachusetts, it smells like dead fish after it's applied. Oh, so you know, I guess there are some uses for beet juice runoff. Okay, yeah. I don't think you should be drinking it. Well, if the next scene is any indication if you should be drinking it. Well, if the next scene is any indication if you should be drinking it,
我想这又是一个“不”。我们闪回到医院候诊室。德怀特和安吉拉在那里。他们在等医生的消息。安吉拉把头发扎成了马尾辫。哦，来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶珍娜·S的粉丝捕捉。等等，我认识洛杉矶的一个珍娜·S。好吧，珍娜有一些问题
I think it's gonna be another no. We flash back to the hospital waiting room. Dwight and Angela are there. They're waiting for news from the doctor. Angela's put her hair in a ponytail. Oh, fan catch from Jenna S in Los Angeles, California. Wait, I know a Jenna S in Los Angeles. Well, Jenna had some questions
关于安吉拉的头发怎么突然扎成了马尾辫。他们在那儿待了多久？为什么我们有一条毯子？我不知道，但医生会出来宣布德怀特不是父亲的消息。是的。然后德怀特会把他的甜菜能量饮料吐在安吉拉身上。
about how Angela's hair is suddenly in a ponytail. And how long have they been there? And why do we have a blanket? I don't know, but the doctor's gonna come out and break the news that Dwight is not the father. Yeah. And then Dwight is gonna vomit his beat energy drink all over Angela.
到处都是。来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶珍娜·F的粉丝捕捉。珍娜为这一集写了很多。是的，她写了。德怀特说他夏天开始制作他的甜菜径流汁。那么他是怎么在医院把它吐在安吉拉身上的，那是在夏天之前？
All over. Fan catch from Jenna F in Los Angeles, California. Jenna wrote in a lot for this episode. Yes, she did. Dwight says he started making his beat runoff juice over the summer. So how did he vomit it all over Angela at the hospital, which was before the summer?
是的，这在拍摄草稿中没有解释。现在安吉拉，来自意大利瓦莱里娅的粉丝提问。显然，我需要知道安吉拉和雷恩是如何拍摄呕吐场景的。我可以清楚地看到一些东西进了安吉拉的嘴里。好吧。我有所有的细节。首先，我扎马尾辫的原因是他们担心这些东西会弄到我的头发上，我们无法快速重置。好吧，对吧？这意味着洗头、吹干头发、拉直头发。
Yes, this was not explained in the shooting draft. And now Angela, fan question from Valeria in Italy. Obviously, I need to know how Angela and Rain shot the vomit scene. I can clearly see that some of the stuff went into Angela's mouth. Okay. I have all the details. First of all, the reason I have a ponytail is because they were worried this stuff was going to get in my hair and we wouldn't be able to reset as quickly. Okay, right? So that would mean washing my hair, blow-drying my hair, flat ironing my hair.
你不能在拍摄间隙做这些。所以这就是为什么扎马尾辫。其次，他们做了这个……看起来像，你知道，当人们去徒步旅行时，他们从那些水袋里喝水，他们有小弯曲的吸管，他们吸。是的，像骆驼背，对吧？是的，就是那个。他们做了其中一个，并把它绑在雷恩的西装外套下面。
You can't do that in between takes. So that's why the ponytail. Secondly, they made this... It looked like, you know, when people go hiking and they drink out of those like pouches of water and they have the little bendy straw, they suck on. Yeah, like camelback, right? Yes, that's it. They made one of these and they sort of strapped it to rain under his blazer jacket.
你不能在拍摄间隙做那个。所以这就是为什么留马尾辫。其次，他们做了这个……看起来就像，你知道，人们去徒步旅行时，从那种水袋里喝水，还有那种可以弯曲的小吸管，他们吸着喝。对，就像骆驼背水袋，对吧？是的，就是那个。他们做了一个，然后把它绑在雷恩的西装外套下面。
Really? So he turned to me when it was time to vomit and just kind of squirted this blue stuff all over me. So it didn't really come out of his mouth? No! I would have never guessed that! You really thought that rain? I had rain spit blue like hurl blue stuff at me? Out of his own mouth? Yes! No! That's what it looked like to me. I would have never guessed that this was rigged. It looked so real. No, it's, look at it. It looks so projectile.
真的吗？所以当他要呕吐的时候，他转向我，然后把这些蓝色的东西喷了我一身。所以那不是从他嘴里吐出来的？不是！我绝对猜不到！你真的以为那是雨？我以为是雨，然后他吐出蓝色的东西，像呕吐物一样喷在我身上？从他自己的嘴里？是的！不是！我当时看起来就是那样。我绝对猜不到这是安排好的。看起来太真实了。不，你看，看那个。看起来太像喷射出来的了。
I know, I couldn't figure out how he did it. It was a little like camel-back thing that he squirted with the hose. He had like a little hose thing. That's why he turned so much to the wall. But yeah, it got all over me. Did you get in your mouth? Some of it went in my mouth.
我知道，我搞不懂他是怎么做到的。就像是一个骆驼背那样的东西，他用软管喷出来的。他有个像小软管一样的东西。这就是为什么他那么转向墙壁。但确实，我身上全都是。你嘴里进去了吗？有一些进到我嘴里了。
How did it taste like? I do think it was like some kind of blue gatorade. I do. I can't remember. It didn't taste horrible. I remember that. And I have a photo backstage after our first take of this where I am doused with all this blue stuff.
味道怎么样？我觉得就像是某种蓝色的佳得乐。真的。我不记得了。味道并不糟糕。我记得这一点。而且在拍完第一条之后，我在后台有一张照片，我浑身都被这些蓝色的东西淋透了。
They had a second set of the wardrobe and a robe for me to change, but I'm just standing in the hallway with my arms out and I'm just covered in this blue liquid. So yeah, I have this great picture in my digital clutter that I'll put in stories of me just covered in the blue beat runoff drink. How many takes did you do? Do you remember? I don't remember, but I think we had to, I know we did too, for sure. And I think we might have gotten it into.
他们准备了第二套服装和一件长袍让我换，但我当时就站在走廊里，张开双臂，浑身都是这种蓝色液体。所以，是的，我的数字杂物里有一张很棒的照片，我会把它发到快拍里，照片里我浑身都是那种蓝色甜菜径流饮料。你们拍了多少条？你记得吗？我不记得了，但我认为我们肯定拍了不止一次。而且我想我们可能把它弄进了。
Mm-hmm. But it was a lot to clean up. Well, before we move on, I would like to give a guest our shout out to the doctor who was played by Oliver Vacour. He's done a mix of comedy and drama. He was most recently in the Barbie movie. And he co-created and wrote a fictional true crime podcast called The Angel of Vine,
嗯哼。但清理起来很麻烦。好吧，在我们继续之前，我想向扮演医生的奥利弗·瓦库尔致敬。他演过喜剧和剧情片。他最近出演了《芭比》电影。他还共同创作并编写了一部名为《藤蔓天使》的虚构真实犯罪播客，
which stars Alfred Molina in Constant Simmer. Oh, your friend Constant. I love Constant. And Monk crossover. My character kills Alfred Molina in Monk. There you go. There you go. Well, we're going to continue finding out what people did over the summer.
由阿尔弗雷德·莫里纳和康斯坦特·西默主演。哦，你的朋友康斯坦特。我喜欢康斯坦特。还有《神探阿蒙》的联动。我的角色在《神探阿蒙》里杀了阿尔弗雷德·莫里纳。你看，就是这样。你看，就是这样。好吧，我们要继续了解大家夏天都做了什么。
Kevin shares that his summer was an emotional roller coaster. I guess he was pulling into the parking lot and he ran over a turtle and then he tried to save him by gluing his shell back together, but he's really not good at puzzles. So he just kind of found random things on his desk to help make the shell. And then as he was trying to rebuild the shell, he just crushed it again with his knee, and then he had to rebuild it even better. But then he thinks maybe the turtle was dead the whole time. We got a fan question from Jenna F in Los Angeles, California, who would like to know if the documentary crew was on a break over the summer,
凯文分享说他的夏天就像坐过山车一样情绪起伏。我猜他当时正开进停车场，结果压死了一只乌龟，然后他试图通过把它的壳粘回去来救它，但他真的不擅长拼图。所以他就在桌子上找了一些乱七八糟的东西来帮忙拼凑那个壳。然后当他试图重建那个壳时，他又用膝盖把它压碎了，然后他不得不把它重建得更好。但后来他觉得也许那只乌龟一直都是死的。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的珍娜·F的粉丝提问，她想知道如果纪录片摄制组在夏天休息，
how did they get all the footage of Kevin running over the turtle and going it back together? Jenna F has caught a lot of continuity errors in this episode. Well, she has questions. I found some fun stuff online about this episode. First of all, there was a great fan catch about the moment where Kevin runs over the turtle. They did a side-by-side of when Michael Scott hits Meredith. The moments are framed exactly the same and both characters go from this moment of like being really happy
他们是怎么拍到凯文压死乌龟并把它拼回去的所有镜头的？珍娜·F在这集中发现了很多连续性错误。好吧，她有问题。我在网上发现了一些关于这一集的有趣内容。首先，有一个很棒的粉丝发现，关于凯文压死乌龟的那一刻。他们做了一个并排对比，对比迈克尔·斯科特撞到梅雷迪斯的时刻。这些时刻的构图完全一样，而且两个角色都从那种非常开心的时刻，
to these looks of like, oh shit. It's funny. And they did a side by side. I'm gonna share it in story. I love that. There was also some online chatter about Kevin's Turtle. Here's something I found on a Reddit thread. A user said season nine, episode one,
变成了那种“哦，糟糕”的表情。这很有趣。他们做了一个并排对比。我会把它分享到快拍里。我喜欢那个。网上还有关于凯文的乌龟的讨论。这是我在Reddit帖子上发现的一些东西。一位用户说第九季第一集，
new guys, is Kevin's Turtle an allegory for the show? Was Greg Daniels acknowledging the state of the show through Kevin? Is the turtle the show? Is Greg Kevin? Oh my gosh. I mean, was the show like run over and then he was trying to piece it back together? Only to discover that it was dead? Oh no! I mean, I hope not. I know. So now we're going to hear about Jim and Pam's summer.
《新来的家伙》，凯文的乌龟是这部剧的寓言吗？格雷格·丹尼尔斯是在通过凯文承认这部剧的状态吗？乌龟就是这部剧吗？格雷格是凯文吗？天哪。我的意思是，这部剧是被压死了，然后他试图把它拼凑回去吗？结果发现它已经死了？哦，不！我的意思是，我希望不是。我知道。所以现在我们要听听吉姆和帕姆的夏天。
They have a talking head together and Pam sort of says nothing new happened, but then Jim says, what are you talking about? You did that mural in the kids' room. Yeah. Lady, I want you to know that was my pitch as producer. Hey! For season nine, one of the things we talked about was Pam's art.
他们一起接受了采访，帕姆说没什么新鲜事发生，但吉姆说，你在说什么？你在孩子房间里画了那幅壁画。是的。女士，我想让你知道那是作为制片人的我的提议。嘿！对于第九季，我们讨论的事情之一就是帕姆的艺术。
And how could this come back into her life? And how could she be expressed creatively? And my son had a mural in his nursery, so did my daughter. We both loved this little detail of our nurseries. And so I said, what if Pam starts painting murals? If this becomes kind of a side gig for her, because we know she's not gonna do graphic design.
这怎么能回到她的生活中？她怎么能进行创造性的表达？我儿子的托儿所里有一幅壁画，我女儿的也有。我们都很喜欢托儿所的这个小细节。所以我说，如果帕姆开始画壁画怎么样？如果这成为她的副业，因为我们知道她不会去做平面设计。
She didn't like it, she didn't take to it. I said, she is a paint on canvas kind of person. Let's follow that thread. So we're starting with this mural in Phillips room. I love that. And now Pam is going to gush on Jim a little bit. She says, you know what? Jim's friend is starting a sports marketing company and it was based on an idea that Jim had back in college. Yeah, and he says he wanted Jim to be part of the company, but you know, it's happening in Philly
她不喜欢，她不适应。我说，她是那种在画布上作画的人。让我们顺着这条线索走下去。所以我们从菲利普房间里的这幅壁画开始。我喜欢那个。现在帕姆要对吉姆赞不绝口了。她说，你知道吗？吉姆的朋友正在创办一家体育营销公司，这是基于吉姆大学时的一个想法。是的，他说他想让吉姆加入公司，但你知道，这发生在费城，
and that didn't really work for their family, but still how cool, right? Yeah, and Jim says, I mean, he'll probably make a billion dollars off my idea. Ha, ha, ha. Hmm, hmm, hmm, planting the seeds. Yes. Well, this was John's pitch.
这对他们的家庭来说不太合适，但还是很酷，对吧？是的，吉姆说，我的意思是，他可能会用我的想法赚十亿美元。哈哈哈哈。嗯，嗯，嗯，播下种子。是的。好吧，这是约翰的提议。
When we were sitting down with Greg talking about season 9, we wanted to talk about what is going to come between Jim and Pam that is not another person. Right. What is going to test their relationship? And John pitched, what if Jim finally has an opportunity outside of Dunder Mifflin, but taking that opportunity is going to cause tension between him and Pam and that is how we got that storyline. I mean I thought it was a really great storyline. Yeah it already made me mad in this episode. We'll get to it. Next up Toby's gonna share
当我们和格雷格坐下来讨论第九季时，我们想谈谈吉姆和帕姆之间会出现什么不是另一个人的问题。对。什么会考验他们的关系？约翰提议，如果吉姆终于有机会离开邓德·米夫林，但抓住这个机会会在他和帕姆之间造成紧张，这就是我们得到那个故事情节的方式。我的意思是，我觉得这是一个非常棒的故事情节。是的，这一集已经让我生气了。我们稍后会讲到。接下来托比要分享
some things that happened over the summer. Kelly is gone. Her fiance, Robby. Fiancé. Yo, yeah, fiance. That's big info. Her fiance, Robby, got a job as a pediatric professor at Miami University. I looked it up. It is a real university in Ohio. It's a public research university was founded in 1809, making it the second oldest university
一些夏天发生的事情。凯利走了。她的未婚夫，罗比。未婚夫。哟，是的，未婚夫。这是大消息。她的未婚夫罗比在迈阿密大学找到了一份儿科教授的工作。我查过了。那是俄亥俄州的一所真正的大学。它是一所成立于1809年的公立研究型大学，是美国第二古老的大学，
in Ohio and the 10th oldest public university in the United States. Well, we got a fan question from Kay Elizabeth in Oxford, Ohio, who is a graduate of Miami University and was also very familiar with the confusion between Miami University and University of Miami. Kelly is of Miami. Yeah. Kelly is also confused. Yes, she believes she's going to Florida. She walks through the office throwing coats at everyone.
也是美国第10古老的公立大学。好吧，我们收到了来自俄亥俄州牛津市的凯·伊丽莎白的粉丝提问，她是迈阿密大学的毕业生，也非常熟悉迈阿密大学和迈阿密大学之间的混淆。凯利去的是迈阿密大学。是的。凯利也很困惑。是的，她以为她要去佛罗里达。她走进办公室，把外套扔向每个人。
I remember this. I do too. I remember after she threw me the coat, I thought, oh, I'm gonna use it to cover my legs in the next scene, because it was freezing. You're like, I'm gonna keep this. Well, it was, you know, in the 90s outside, so they crank the air on the inside. K Elizabeth went on to say, quote, my fellow Redhawks are all too familiar with the fact that
我记得这个。我也记得。我记得在她扔给我外套后，我想，哦，我下一场戏可以用它来盖住我的腿，因为太冷了。你当时就像，我要留着这个。好吧，你知道，外面是90多度，所以他们在室内把空调开得很大。凯·伊丽莎白接着说，引用，“我的红鹰校友们都非常熟悉这样一个事实，即
Miami University was an established school before Florida was even a state. Yeah. And often get Florida-related questions from non-ohioans. Mm-hmm. Toby is then going to share that Ryan quit shortly after Kelly left and moved to Ohio for, quote, unrelated reasons. Then we see Ryan at a bus stop with his luggage, trash bags full of clothes.
迈阿密大学在佛罗里达州建州之前就已经是一所成熟的学校了。”是的。而且经常从非俄亥俄州人那里收到与佛罗里达相关的问题。嗯哼。托比随后要分享说瑞安在凯利离开后不久就辞职了，并以“无关原因”搬到了俄亥俄州。然后我们看到瑞安在公交车站，带着他的行李，装满衣服的垃圾袋。
He says, based on market research, Southern Western Ohio is the Silicon Prairie, aka the next Silicon Valley. Fan deep dive from Elliott Kay in Southwest Ohio, who says, I cannot wait for you to address the opening when Ryan leaves the office suddenly to follow Kelly. Of course, Ryan needs an excuse to not just be following a girl, so he claims that he's leaving for Southwest Ohio because it is the next Silicon Valley, which he calls the Silicon Prairie. But, this opening grates on me like nails on a chalkboard every time for two reasons. Do you want to hear why Elliott is so annoyed? Elliott, I would love nothing more.
他说，根据市场研究，俄亥俄州西南部是硅草原，也就是下一个硅谷。来自俄亥俄州西南部的埃利奥特·凯的粉丝深度挖掘，他说，我迫不及待地想让你们谈谈瑞安突然离开办公室去追凯利的那段开场。当然，瑞安需要一个借口，不能只是去追一个女孩，所以他声称他要去俄亥俄州西南部，因为那是下一个硅谷，他称之为硅草原。但是，这个开场每次都让我像指甲刮黑板一样难受，原因有两个。你想听听为什么埃利奥特这么烦吗？埃利奥特，我最想听了。
Elliott is annoyed because Southwest Ohio is hundreds of miles away from the nearest prairie. But more importantly, Elliot is annoyed because Southwest Ohio was the original Silicon Valley. Oh, so the stings, Elliot, it does. Elliot says, have you ever flown on a plane, started a car, bought something requiring a cash register, opened a can of pop, used an ice tray, eaten a cheese it, because all of these things and many more were invented in Dayton, Ohio. Daytonians are a proud people,
埃利奥特很烦，因为俄亥俄州西南部距离最近的草原有数百英里远。但更重要的是，埃利奥特很烦，因为俄亥俄州西南部才是真正的硅谷发源地。哦，所以这很刺耳，埃利奥特，确实。埃利奥特说，你有没有坐过飞机，发动过汽车，买过需要收银机的东西，打开过一罐汽水，用过冰格，吃过芝士脆饼？因为所有这些东西以及更多东西都是在俄亥俄州代顿发明的。代顿人是一个自豪的民族，
so you please do what you can to set the record straight. P.S., don't let North Carolina fool you. Ohio invented flight. Wow, Elliot! Yeah. Hot to try. Sure is. That's a lot of impressive things that were created in Dayton.
所以请尽你所能澄清事实。附注：别让北卡罗来纳州骗了你。俄亥俄州发明了飞行。哇，埃利奥特！是的。很想尝试。确实是。代顿创造了这么多令人印象深刻的东西。
Should we go to Dayton? I bet there's a museum about it. I bet there's a factory. Oh, there's got to be a factory or two. For the cheese it, maybe? The cheese it factory is in Ohio. Come on, Elliot. to be a factory or two. For the cheese it, maybe the cheese it factory. Is it in Ohio? Come on, Elliott, tell us which factory to go to in Dayton.
我们要去代顿吗？我敢打赌那里有一个关于它的博物馆。我敢打赌那里有一家工厂。哦，肯定有一两家工厂。为了芝士脆饼，也许？芝士脆饼工厂在俄亥俄州。来吧，埃利奥特。肯定有一两家工厂。为了芝士脆饼，也许芝士脆饼工厂。它在俄亥俄州吗？来吧，埃利奥特，告诉我们去代顿哪家工厂。
Thank you for sending in that deep dive. We're happy to set the record straight. Yes. Next up, Jim and Pam are going to say, well, that's our summer. And they're going to start to take off their mic packs. This was huge. This is part of Greg's plan to start really showing the documentary crew, right? And we're going to hear the voice of the documentarian.
感谢你发来那次深度挖掘。我们很高兴澄清事实。是的。接下来，吉姆和帕姆要说，好吧，这就是我们的夏天。他们要开始摘下麦克风包了。这太重要了。这是格雷格计划的一部分，开始真正展示纪录片摄制组，对吧？我们要听到纪录片制作者的声音。
Dave Rogers. Yes, our editor and sometimes director. Pam says something we've all been thinking. She says, don't you guys have all the footage you need? It's just a paper company. Yes, and the documentarian says, well, we're actually kind of following you guys. I think meaning all of you guys, right, in your lives. And Pam sort of says, well, listen, you can follow us, but I don't think anything interesting
戴夫·罗杰斯。是的，我们的剪辑师，有时也是导演。帕姆说了我们大家都在想的一件事。她说，你们难道没有拍到所有需要的镜头了吗？这只是一家造纸公司。是的，纪录片制作者说，嗯，我们实际上是在跟踪你们。我想是指你们所有人，对吧，在你们的生活中。帕姆说，好吧，听着，你可以跟着我们，但我不认为有什么有趣的事情
is going to happen to us for a long, long time. We're in a routine, a life routine called work and kids. Oh, pushing on Jim's face, right? Oh, Lord. This was another one of the pitches that we came up with over the summer, which was that Pam is happy and content and Jim starts to get a little restless, which I think is a very relatable, very rough thing in a merit. I think it is. The show's going to start. Aaron is still very excited telling everyone, Andy's coming back. And we got a fan mail flurry about her new curly hair.
会在很长很长一段时间内发生在我们身上。我们处于一种常规中，一种叫做工作和孩子的生活常规。哦，推着吉姆的脸，对吧？哦，天哪。这是我们夏天想出的另一个提议，那就是帕姆快乐满足，而吉姆开始变得有点不安，我认为这在婚姻中是非常容易产生共鸣、非常艰难的事情。我认为是。节目要开始了。艾琳仍然非常兴奋地告诉大家，安迪要回来了。我们收到了一堆关于她新卷发的粉丝邮件。
She's standing at the window and the sunlight is coming in and you can very clearly see that her hair has bumped up to a much brighter red color. Yeah. It's curly. And M from Florida said, holy moly, Erin's wavy hair is awesome. Tally M from Canada said,
她站在窗边，阳光照进来，你可以非常清楚地看到她的头发变成了更明亮的红色。是的。是卷发。来自佛罗里达州的M说，天哪，艾琳的波浪发太棒了。来自加拿大的塔利·M说，
this new-cred style looks amazing. And Jasmine B from Southern Manitoba said, Erin's hair evolution is similar to Pam's. Was this intentional? The color change from Brunette to red is similar to Pam's. Her hairstyle is mirroring that of Pam's when she started styling it with heat. Were they trying to keep the comfort and familiarity of Pam reception via Erin's hair? Hmm. Guess what?
这种新发型看起来太棒了。来自曼尼托巴省南部的茉莉·B说，艾琳的发型演变和帕姆的很像。这是故意的吗？从棕色到红色的颜色变化和帕姆的很像。她的发型模仿了帕姆开始用热工具造型时的样子。他们是想通过艾琳的头发来保持帕姆前台的舒适感和熟悉感吗？嗯。猜猜怎么着？
What? I have no answers. I don't know. Wait a moment, Mom, Detective. Well, you know what? I think she had some time away from Andy. Maybe she's trying to find herself a little. You know, that's what we said when Pam changed her hair. Usually when women change their hair, they're going through something. Just word to the wise. Well, our two new employees enter the bullpen. They
什么？我没有答案。我不知道。等一下，妈妈，侦探。好吧，你知道吗？我想她离开安迪有一段时间了。也许她正在努力寻找自我。你知道，这就是帕姆换发型时我们说的话。通常当女性换发型时，她们正在经历一些事情。忠告一句。好吧，我们的两名新员工进入了办公区。他们
ask where they can throw away coffee filters. They get a lot of Stanley and Phyllis sass. They really do. Just right away. Toby has a talking head where he says the new guys back in the annex are in their 20s and he gets long really great with them. They all play video games and their computers. Although it looks like Toby is really bad at it.
问在哪里可以扔掉咖啡滤纸。他们受到了斯坦利和菲利斯的冷嘲热讽。他们确实受到了。就在那一刻。托比有一个采访，他说附件里的新家伙才20多岁，他和他们相处得很好。他们都在电脑上玩电子游戏。虽然看起来托比真的很不擅长。
Yeah. They're just three single guys getting into trouble. Well, there are two delicious candy bag alts for this Toby talking head. They were in the shooting draft. I want to share them with you. Here's one. Toby would have said, there's two new guys back here with me going through Kelly's old complaints.
是的。他们只是三个单身汉，惹上了麻烦。好吧，这个托比的采访有两个美味的糖果袋替代方案。它们在拍摄草稿里。我想和你们分享。这是其中一个。托比会说，这里有两个新家伙和我一起处理凯利的旧投诉。
They're in their 20s and we really get along. Maybe that's been my problem. I was born in the wrong generation. Well, that's one of my problems. Hmm. Why, why? And here's the other one. There are two new guys in the annex with me now.
他们20多岁，我们真的很合得来。也许这就是我的问题所在。我出生在错误的时代。好吧，那是我的问题之一。嗯。为什么，为什么？这是另一个。现在附件里有两个新家伙和我在一起。
Young guys in their 20s. I don't have a lot of friends. So it's nice to finally have two best friends. Oh, two. Oh, two. Stop breaking my heart, bud. Oh, Tobi! Oh, Tobi! Stop breaking my heart, bud. Oh, come on. Ugh.
20多岁的年轻人。我没有很多朋友。所以终于有两个最好的朋友真是太好了。哦，两个。哦，两个。别伤我的心，伙计。哦，托比！哦，托比！别伤我的心，伙计。哦，得了吧。呃。
Well, Stanley is gonna say that the new guys are like the new Jim and Dwight. Nelly agrees, Phyllis agrees. Jim and Dwight don't quite see it. Meredith invites new Jim to sit on her face. He says, no, thank you. And also says his name is Pete. Jim is going to have a talking head where he says Pete is not the new Jim. The only thing they
好吧，斯坦利要说新来的家伙就像新的吉姆和德怀特。内莉同意，菲利斯同意。吉姆和德怀特并不这么认为。梅雷迪斯邀请新吉姆坐在她的脸上。他说，不，谢谢。还说他的名字叫皮特。吉姆要有一个采访，他说皮特不是新的吉姆。他们唯一的共同点是
have in common is that they both don't want to sit on Meredith's face. And if that makes him the new Jim, then every human in the world is new Jim. I thought that was really funny. I did do. Greg said that from a story telling standpoint, the theme of the year was kind of a realization from both Dwight and Jim that they had been at Dunder Mifflin for a very long time. By having these new guys come in, who everybody was calling the new Dwight and the new Jim was a way to have Dwight and Jim think about just how long they've been in the same job and maybe to prod them into getting their lives moving into the next stage.
他们都不想坐在梅雷迪斯的脸上。如果这让他成为新的吉姆，那么世界上每个人都是新的吉姆。我觉得这真的很有趣。我也这么认为。格雷格说，从讲故事的角度来看，这一年的主题是德怀特和吉姆都意识到他们在邓德·米夫林待了很长时间。通过让这些每个人都称之为新德怀特和新吉姆的新人进来，是一种让德怀特和吉姆思考他们在这个岗位上待了多久的方式，也许是为了促使他们让生活进入下一个阶段。
Well now it's time for a Get to Know Your Cast and Crew moment from our call sheet. Yay! This one is about Anna Coats, who was our key assistant location manager. Three things you didn't know about Anna Coats. Anna's favorite book is The Poison Wood Bible. It's about four sisters from Africa. She enjoyed rolling down hills as a child and now looks forward to long runs. If time traveling were an option, she would go to the 1960s, then the 40s, then shopping. Oh, there you go.
好吧，现在是我们的通告单上的“了解你的演员和工作人员”时刻。耶！这一条是关于安娜·科茨的，她是我们的首席助理外景经理。关于安娜·科茨你不知道的三件事。安娜最喜欢的书是《毒木圣经》。它是关于非洲四个姐妹的故事。她小时候喜欢从山上滚下来，现在期待长跑。如果可以选择时间旅行，她会去20世纪60年代，然后是40年代，然后去购物。哦，就是这样。
You just got to know, our key assistant location manager, I am going to tell you right now that I'm going to need this to become a regular thing. I should have been doing it all along. Nothing like picking something up in the last couple of days. I am going to tell you right now that I'm going to need this to become a regular thing. I should have been doing it all along. Nothing like picking something up in the last stretch, Ann.
你刚刚了解了我们的首席助理外景经理，我现在要告诉你，我需要让这成为一件常态化的事情。我本应该一直这样做的。没有什么比在最后几天学到东西更好的了。我现在要告诉你，我需要让这成为一件常态化的事情。我本应该一直这样做的。没有什么比在最后阶段学到东西更好的了，安。
Guess what, everyone? Andy finally walks in the door. Apparently, when you come back to work for the first time, you're allowed to be late. He missed everyone, and he is immediately a jerk. Immediately. Immediately. He wants to know why Nelly's still working there. He said he had a dream she died and then says, meet me in my office later.
猜猜怎么着，大家？安迪终于走进门了。显然，当你第一次回来工作时，你是可以迟到的。他想念每个人，而且他立刻就变成了一个混蛋。立刻。立刻。他想知道为什么内莉还在那里工作。他说他梦见她死了，然后说，稍后在我的办公室见我。
Well, I'm going to call a bullsh**t card here. What is it? Because at the end of Free Family Portrait, Andy calls Nelly a sly bastard and hires her back as special project manager. This was my question earlier. Yes, they even shake on it. Right! So I'm like, what happened? How did outward bound make Andy a colossal ass?
好吧，我要在这里叫一张“胡说八道”牌。是什么？因为在《免费家庭肖像》的结尾，安迪称内莉为狡猾的混蛋，并重新聘用她为特别项目经理。这是我之前的问题。是的，他们甚至握手言和了。对！所以我当时想，发生了什么？外展训练怎么让安迪变成了一个巨大的混蛋？
I found this in the shooting draft. It doesn't help much, but it might have tipped off why Nelly was nervous. Okay. Andy calls Toby into his office and says, hey, why is Nelly still here? Didn't you get my postcard? Toby has a talking head where he's holding up a postcard.
我在拍摄草稿里发现了这个。没什么帮助，但它可能暗示了为什么内莉很紧张。好吧。安迪把托比叫进他的办公室说，嘿，为什么内莉还在？你没收到我的明信片吗？托比有一个采访，他拿着一张明信片。
He shows the postcard to the camera and says, on the front is a pretty waterfall. On the back it says, fire Nelly. Then he smells it and says, I don't think this is ink. Oh, well. What did he write it in says, I don't think this is ink. Oh, well. Why did he write it in? We don't know. But it does tell us that Toby might have known that Andy wanted Nelly gone.
他把明信片展示给镜头看，说，正面是一个漂亮的瀑布。背面写着，解雇内莉。然后他闻了闻说，我不认为这是墨水。哦，好吧。他用什么写的，说，我不认为这是墨水。哦，好吧。他用什么写的？我们不知道。但这确实告诉我们，托比可能知道安迪想让内莉走人。
Okay. Okay. Okay. Now Andy's going to greet the new guys and he's going to give them nicknames. Yeah. He said because outward bound is all about nicknames. His was Iceman. He decides, he will be plop because outward bound is all about nicknames. His was Iceman. He decides, P will be Plop because he dumps all the time
好吧。好吧。好吧。现在安迪要迎接新来的家伙，他要给他们起绰号。是的。他说因为外展训练全是关于绰号的。他的是冰人。他决定，他将是“噗噗”，因为外展训练全是关于绰号的。他的是冰人。他决定，皮特将是“噗噗”，因为他总是拉肚子，
and he was gonna call Clark Fart, because they both do these things constantly. Even though he doesn't know them at all, doesn't know any of their BMs. You know what? We got a fan question from Jenna F in Los Angeles, California. Oh, Jenna wrote in again? Who would like to know?
他打算叫克拉克“屁”，因为他们俩总是做这些事。尽管他根本不了解他们，不知道他们的任何排便情况。你知道吗？我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的珍娜·F的粉丝提问。哦，珍娜又写信来了？她想知道，
Who hired the new guys if Andy was away? Oh, Janna wrote in again, who would like to know who hired the new guys if Andy was away? Oh, good call. And was there a postcard to Toby saying hire two new guys? Yeah, I want to make fun of them and call them plop and fart. Exactly. Darryl says they've been calling Clark Dwight Jr. Clark says I prefer fart. I know. But Dwight is very excited about this idea. He's like in a way, he has a son. Maybe someday, though, hire someone who looks like a younger clerk, and then he'll have a grand son. So ridiculous. It's so incredibly ridiculous. Well, next up starts a storyline for Angela, but I think we should take a break, and then we'll come back and
如果安迪不在，是谁雇了新来的家伙？哦，珍娜又写信来了，她想知道如果安迪不在，是谁雇了新来的家伙？哦，好问题。有没有给托比的明信片说雇两个新家伙？是的，我想取笑他们，叫他们“噗噗”和“屁”。没错。达里尔说他们一直叫克拉克“小德怀特”。克拉克说我更喜欢“屁”。我知道。但德怀特对这个想法非常兴奋。他就像在某种程度上，他有一个儿子。也许有一天，雇一个看起来像年轻克拉克的人，然后他就会有一个孙子。太荒谬了。这太不可思议地荒谬了。好吧，接下来是安吉拉的故事情节，但我认为我们应该休息一下，然后回来
discuss the re-homing of Comstock. Yes. It also has a line that I get quoted a lot. I know it. Well, we're back and we're over in accounting. Angela's sharing that she has to put up one of her cats for adoption. Kevin wonders which one and starts listing them. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Kevin, the one who uses the doorbell or the one with the Mexican hat or the one with the rain glosses or the one you let go around naked. Angela says, no, the one with the long hair and the denim pants, Comstock. She shows Kevin and Oscar photos of Comstock and this is what the shooting draft said.
讨论康斯托克的重新安置。是的。它还有一句我经常被引用的台词。我知道。好吧，我们回来了，我们在会计部。安吉拉分享说她必须把她的一只猫送去领养。凯文想知道是哪一只，并开始列举它们。这就是拍摄草稿里的内容。凯文，那个会用门铃的，还是那个戴墨西哥帽的，还是那个戴雨镜的，还是那个你让它裸体到处跑的？安吉拉说，不，那个长毛穿牛仔裤的，康斯托克。她给凯文和奥斯卡看了康斯托克的照片，这就是拍摄草稿里说的。
There's a video of a long haired cat in little jeans sitting on a motorcycle and sitting on a pillow being hugged by the senator as the song, nobody Does It Better, plays. The videos of Comstock were some of the first scenes that we filmed on day two of filming this episode, which was July 31st, and there were some additional notes on the call sheet for this day. Here's one, there will be a large working crane in the main parking lot. Please see attached memo regarding where to park across the street. Second announcement. A slackline rehearsal will take place for Dwight and Clark in the swing set area of the warehouse. More slackline rehearsal. Second slackline rehearsal for those guys. Kevin is now going to offer to take Comstock but Angela quickly rejects this because of, hello, the turtle. Okay.
有一段视频，一只长毛猫穿着小牛仔裤坐在摩托车上，坐在枕头上被参议员拥抱，背景音乐是《没人比我做得更好》。康斯托克的视频是我们拍摄这一集第二天，也就是7月31日拍摄的第一批场景之一，通告单上还有一些额外的说明。这是其中一条，主停车场将有一台大型工作起重机。请参阅关于在街对面停车的附录备忘录。第二个公告。德怀特和克拉克将在仓库的秋千区进行扁带排练。更多扁带排练。第二次扁带排练。凯文现在要主动提出收养康斯托克，但安吉拉很快拒绝了，因为，你好，那只乌龟。好吧。
Hey, Kevin is enormously proud of what he did for that turtle. She says, Oscar, will you take him? And he says, no, I'm a dog person. And here, for those of you who know all of Angela Martin's famous lines is one of my famous lines. If you pray enough, you can change yourself into a cat person.
嘿，凯文对他为那只乌龟所做的事情感到非常自豪。她说，奥斯卡，你会收养它吗？他说，不，我是个爱狗人士。在这里，对于那些了解安吉拉·马丁所有名言的人来说，这是我的名言之一。如果你祈祷得足够多，你可以把自己变成一个爱猫人士。
Mm-hmm. And Oscar says those guys always turn back Angela. I know. So funny. And we got a fan question from Ellen C. In Scotland who said, I have a theory that Angela got her cat comp stock when she was dating Andy. And that maybe it was Andy who named the cat. Because I noticed that in season five, episode six, when Andy is getting annoyed with Dwight for applying to Cornell, Dwight references Comstock Hall,
嗯哼。奥斯卡说那些家伙总是会变回来的，安吉拉。我知道。太搞笑了。我们收到了来自苏格兰的艾伦·C的粉丝提问，她说，我有一个理论，安吉拉是在和安迪约会时得到她的猫康斯托克的。而且也许是安迪给猫起的名字。因为我注意到在第五季第六集，当安迪因为德怀特申请康奈尔大学而感到恼火时，德怀特提到了康斯托克大厅，
which is a building at Cornell. Could that be the story behind Comstock, the cat's name? Ellen, I saw a few comments like this. I think it's really a great catch. I mean, I like to think that Andy got her this cat, but I think she is also worried about Phillips allergies. Yep. I like to think that everyone Angela ever dated got her a cat.
那是康奈尔大学的一栋建筑。这可能是康斯托克这个猫名的由来吗？艾伦，我看到了几个这样的评论。我认为这是一个非常棒的发现。我的意思是，我喜欢认为安迪给她买了这只猫，但我认为她也担心菲利普的过敏。是的。我喜欢认为安吉拉约会过的每个人都给她买过猫。
She has livestock, she has garbage. Yeah. We are now in Andy's office. He's getting off the phone with David Wallace. Toby enters and Andy is going to ask him why Nelly is still there. And Toby says you know what? He can only fire her for cause. So Andy has decided that he's going to try to make something up to get her fired.
她有牲畜，她有垃圾。是的。我们现在在安迪的办公室。他刚和戴维·华莱士通完电话。托比进来了，安迪要问他为什么内莉还在那里。托比说你知道吗？他只能因为正当理由解雇她。所以安迪决定他要试着编造一些事情让她被解雇。
Yeah, but Toby says, well, now we can't fire her because you told me that it's going to be made up. And now I know. Yeah. And Andy's like, well, forget I said that. And Toby says, I can't forget because I went to the wine-trop memory academy. Yes. Not real, I looked.
是的，但托比说，好吧，现在我们不能解雇她了，因为你告诉我这是编造的。现在我知道了。是的。安迪说，好吧，忘了我说过的话。托比说，我不能忘，因为我去了温特罗普记忆学院。是的。不是真的，我查过了。
Not real, I looked it up. Toby says I sat next to Beverly Brook who ate a Greek salad for lunch. And Andy goes, I now understand why Michael hated you so much. Dwight is now going to approach Clark in the break room. This line made me laugh so hard. Which one? He? There's so many. But when Dwight invites him to a slayer concert that's ten months away, it's like who does that? It made me very curious, though. I was like, what is invitation etiquette? I went to EmilyPost.com.
不是真的，我查过了。托比说我坐在贝弗利·布鲁克旁边，她午餐吃的是希腊沙拉。安迪说，我现在明白为什么迈克尔那么讨厌你了。德怀特现在要走近休息室里的克拉克。这句台词让我笑得太厉害了。哪一句？他？有太多了。但当德怀特邀请他参加十个月后的杀手乐队演唱会时，就像谁会那样做？这让我很好奇。我当时想，邀请礼仪是什么？我去了EmilyPost.com。
Here's what they say for a few different types of gatherings. Anniversary party, three to six weeks. Notice, notice, okay. Holiday dinner, two weeks to two months. Okay, formal dinner, three to six weeks. Graduation party, three weeks, notice, lunch or tea a few days to two weeks. They did not have any tips for how long in advance you invite someone to a concert, but I did find a Reddit thread inspired by this episode that said around three months.
这是他们对几种不同聚会的建议。周年纪念派对，三到六周。通知，通知，好的。节日晚餐，两周到两个月。好的，正式晚餐，三到六周。毕业派对，三周，通知，午餐或茶会几天到两周。他们没有任何关于提前多久邀请别人参加演唱会的建议，但我确实发现了一个受这一集启发的Reddit帖子，上面说大约三个月。
Well listen, if you want to go see a Taylor Swift concert, you might need to talk about it 10 months in advance. Oh, yeah. Okay. Okay, in advance. Yes. So sometimes I think it depends on who's playing. Yeah.
好吧，听着，如果你想去看泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会，你可能需要提前10个月谈论它。哦，是的。好的。好的，提前。是的。所以我有时认为这取决于谁在表演。是的。
Well, Clark is going to tell Dwight he'll be busy in 10 months. Yeah, he's pretty sure he's busy that night. Yeah. So Dwight's going to pivot. He's like, dude, what's up with you? Like, let's talk farming. Yeah, are you a fruit guy or a root guy? And Clark said, is this some sort of code for gay stuff?
好吧，克拉克要告诉德怀特他十个月后会很忙。是的，他很确定那天晚上他很忙。是的。所以德怀特要转变话题。他就像，伙计，你怎么了？让我们谈谈农业。是的，你是水果派还是根茎派？克拉克说，这是某种关于同性恋的暗语吗？
Because I mean, I'm totally fine with it, but I'm into the ladies. Spoken like a true root man. And then Clark says, hey, if you're ever swapped, maybe I could take some of your sales calls. Oh no. Now do I just don't, You're not my son anymore. I know. Over you. It's done. It's a quick turn. Oh yeah. Dwight is going to go warn Jim. I think
因为我的意思是，我完全没问题，但我喜欢女士。说得像个真正的根茎派男人。然后克拉克说，嘿，如果你忙不过来，也许我可以接手你的一些销售电话。哦，不。现在德怀特就像，你不再是我的儿子了。我知道。结束了。很快。哦，是的。德怀特要警告吉姆。我想
the new guys are trying to take our jobs. Yeah. And so Jim immediately decides to mess with him and says, Oh yeah, that must be what Pete was talking about at the sales meeting yesterday. Dwight's like, what sales meeting? What are you talking about? Yeah, I guess Clark ended the meeting with Karate. Apparently he's above a black belt. Oh, lady. The scene was longer, it was. And Dwight keeps coming back and reporting to Jim about it. And I need to play a clip because there's a Star Wars reference. Psst. Clark just told me that he never studied Karate. Why would he lie to me? play a clip because there. What Star Wars are you watching? Luke is trying to destroy Darth Vader.
新来的家伙正试图抢我们的工作。是的。所以吉姆立刻决定捉弄他，说，哦，是的，那一定是皮特昨天在销售会议上谈论的事情。德怀特说，什么销售会议？你在说什么？是的，我猜克拉克用空手道结束了会议。显然他超过了黑带。哦，女士。那个场景更长，确实。德怀特不断回来向吉姆报告这件事。我需要播放一段片段，因为有一个《星球大战》的引用。嘘。克拉克刚告诉我他从来没学过空手道。他为什么要对我撒谎？播放一段片段，因为那里。你在看什么《星球大战》？卢克正试图摧毁达斯·维达。
Well, Angela, as you know, I understood that entire scene. I understood why it is funny. I chuckled along with it because we revealed on our Monday mailbag episode that ran back in December that I watched Star Wars. She watched Star Wars and didn't tell me. So if you wanna hear it and you wanna hear Angela's reaction, go back and listen. My reaction and Sam's, we couldn't believe it.
好吧，安吉拉，如你所知，我理解了整个场景。我理解为什么它很有趣。我跟着笑了，因为我们在十二月播出的周一邮件袋节目中透露过，我看过《星球大战》。她看过《星球大战》却没告诉我。所以如果你想听听，想听听安吉拉的反应，回去听听。我的反应和萨姆的反应，我们简直不敢相信。
Angela now addresses the bull pin. She has a flyer for Comstock and she shares that he needs a home and she'll be conducting 20 minute interviews for anyone interested. Phil Shee made those flyers. I even kept one in my trailer for a long time. Oh, yeah, I had it hanging in my trailer for so long. I'm gonna try to find it. It's probably in one of my bins. Why did I keep these things? I'm like such a little rat packer. I'm like, I'll put it in my scrapbook. But anyway, Angela goes over her criteria for her candidates in true Angela fashion. And she tells Pam she really needs to hour, but she's still in the running. Yeah. Pam is like, I never entered this contest. Well, time to turn on the
安吉拉现在向办公区讲话。她有一张康斯托克的传单，她分享说他需要一个家，她将为任何感兴趣的人进行20分钟的面试。菲尔·谢制作了那些传单。我甚至在我的拖车里留了一张很长时间。哦，是的，我把它挂在我的拖车里很久了。我要试着找到它。它可能在我的一个箱子里。我为什么要留着这些东西？我就像个小囤积狂。我就像，我会把它放进我的剪贴簿里。但无论如何，安吉拉以真正的安吉拉方式列出了她的候选人标准。她告诉帕姆她真的需要面试，但她还在竞争中。是的。帕姆就像，我从来没参加过这个比赛。好吧，是时候展现
charm. Next up, Andy is called Nellie into his office. And this scene is really going to make the original title of this episode make sense, because there's going to be a lot of workplace bullying. Yeah, he says he doesn't like to throw The original title of this episode makes sense because there's going to be a lot of workplace bullying. Yeah. He says he doesn't like to throw around the beward, but he's going to be a huge bitch to her.
魅力了。接下来，安迪把内莉叫进了他的办公室。这个场景真的会让这一集的原始标题变得有意义，因为会有很多职场欺凌。是的，他说他不喜欢随便说那个词，但他要对她非常刻薄。
Yeah. God, Andy. I know. He doesn't stop there. He's now set up in the parking lot, a slackline to teach focus and discipline, and in some cases humiliation. Yeah. and discipline and in some cases humiliation. Yeah, he's gathered everyone down in the parking lot and he says, we're going to walk across it.
是的。天哪，安迪。我知道。他并没有就此罢休。他现在在停车场设置了一个扁带，用来教专注和纪律，在某些情况下是羞辱。是的。和纪律，在某些情况下是羞辱。是的，他把每个人都召集到停车场，他说，我们要走过去。
And if you make it, you're going to feel awesome, but if you Toby out, you're going to feel like a real nelly. Yeah. He's also brought along a couple of the instructors from his outward bound trip, rave and feather. Yeah. So this scene would have continued. I was in the script looking up some descriptions of the stunts, and I came across this little nugget.
如果你成功了，你会感觉很棒，但如果你像托比一样，你会感觉像个真正的内莉。是的。他还带了几个他外展训练旅行的教练，雷夫和费瑟。是的。所以这个场景本来会继续。我在剧本里查找一些特技的描述，我发现了这个小金块。
You know, Andy is referring to these guys by their outward bound names, and they are going to refer to Andy as Iceman, right? And then Rave is going to explain to camera, we call him Iceman because he always complained about his canteen water being warm. That's how Andy got his nickname. Not because he was like really tough and we could be out there freezing and be fine.
你知道，安迪用他们的外展名字称呼这些人，他们会称安迪为冰人，对吧？然后雷夫要向镜头解释，我们叫他冰人是因为他总是抱怨他的水壶里的水是温的。这就是安迪得到绰号的原因。不是因为他真的很强硬，我们可以在外面冻着也没事。
While Rafe and Feather are helping set up, Gem is gonna find out that he has nothing in common with Plop. Yeah, he really tries to bond with him, but there's nothing. He lists a bunch of things and there's nothing. No. We had a fan question from David H. and Preston England who wanted to know who plays Feather, the tightrope guy. He's not listed on IMDB.
当雷夫和费瑟帮忙设置时，吉姆会发现他和“噗噗”没有任何共同点。是的，他真的试图和他建立联系，但什么都没有。他列举了一堆事情，但什么都没有。不。我们收到了来自英国普雷斯顿的戴维·H的粉丝提问，他想知道是谁扮演了费瑟，那个走钢丝的家伙。他没有在IMDB上列出。
Well, David, it was Cody Gilbert and he is a professional stunt person. The character of Rafe was played by Jeff B. First up on the slackline, Andy's gonna make Nelly go. He says, take off your heels, get up there. She says, no, I'd rather keep them on. I'm very insecure about my feet. So she gets up on the slackline in high heels.
好吧，戴维，那是科迪·吉尔伯特，他是一名专业特技演员。雷夫这个角色由杰夫·B扮演。扁带上的第一个，安迪要让内莉上。他说，脱掉你的高跟鞋，上去。她说，不，我宁愿穿着它们。我对我的脚很没自信。所以她穿着高跟鞋上了扁带。
Yeah. And we don't even know if she can do it because Andy immediately pushes her off face down. Yes. So we had a stunt person for Catherine Tate. Catherine stunt person was Jennifer Cobb, but Catherine still had to try and get up on that slackline with the high heels. Before we cut to the fall, that was really her in high heels getting up on that slackline. It was bonkers. I can't believe that you can just shove someone to the ground at work and not have any
是的。我们甚至不知道她能不能做到，因为安迪立刻把她推了下去，脸朝下。是的。所以我们为凯瑟琳·塔特准备了一名特技演员，凯瑟琳的特技演员是詹妮弗·科布，但凯瑟琳仍然必须尝试穿着高跟鞋上那个扁带。在我们切到摔倒之前，那真的是她穿着高跟鞋上那个扁带。太疯狂了。我不敢相信你可以在工作中把某人推倒在地而没有任何
repercussions. I mean, don't get me started. Don't get me started. There's a little something in the shooting draft I'm going to share here in a minute where they would have tried to address it. Clark is now going to volunteer. He gives it a try. Any crush is it. Yep. This is going to inspire Dwight to try. I mean, Dwight Jr. did it. Let's see Dwight Sr. do it.
后果。我的意思是，别让我开始说。别让我开始说。拍摄草稿里有一点东西，我一会儿会分享，他们本来会试图解决这个问题。克拉克现在要自愿尝试。他试了一下。安迪压制了他。是的。这会激励德怀特尝试。我的意思是，小德怀特做到了。让我们看看老德怀特做到了。
Yeah, it doesn't go well. How many times could one person fall off a slackline? There was one time when he falls on his shoulder and I could barely watch it because it reminded me of breaking my own shoulder. We had fan questions from Ashley O. in Utah and Heather F. in California who wanted to know did Reign perform his own stunts? Was it choreographed
是的，结果不太好。一个人能从扁带上摔下来多少次？有一次他摔在肩膀上，我几乎不敢看，因为它让我想起了我自己的肩膀骨折。我们收到了来自犹他州的阿什利·O和加利福尼亚州的希瑟·F的粉丝提问，他们想知道雷恩是自己表演特技吗？是编排好的
or planned how he would fall? Did Reign make any of the creative decisions on how he would fall? Well, I'll tell you guys, it was Reign and it was also his stunt double Kevin Foster who is also the person who doubles for him later on the bicycle, will get to it. But the descriptions for how he falls were meticulously scripted, and I have them here to read to you. First up, Dwight tries to step onto the slackline and is immediately pitched forward into a summer salt and onto the mat. We saw that move. Next up, Dwight leaps onto the slackline again and is flung off even more violently. He crawls around looking
还是计划好的他怎么摔倒？雷恩对怎么摔倒做了任何创意决定吗？好吧，我告诉你们，那是雷恩，也是他的特技替身凯文·福斯特，他也是后来在自行车上替他的人，我们稍后会讲到。但关于他怎么摔倒的描述是精心编写的，我在这里读给你们听。首先，德怀特试图踏上扁带，立刻向前翻了个跟头摔在垫子上。我们看到了那个动作。接下来，德怀特再次跳上扁带，被甩得更猛烈。他爬来爬去寻找
for his glasses and one of his shoes. Next, Dwight keeps trying and gets flung off each time. Add lib trash talking from Clark. It was a note in the script. Finally, it says Dwight has a bloody lip. Nobody understands what he's saying. Dwight becomes frustrated and runs off saying, Buck, you brother-buckers. I did love that he tried the door and it wouldn't open. Me too. I feel like that's so classic when you want to quickly get away from a situation and you can't. Yes. Well, immediately after this slackline scene, Toby would have called a conference room meeting about workplace bullying. It was in the shooting draft.
他的眼镜和一只鞋子。接下来，德怀特不断尝试，每次都被甩下来。克拉克的即兴垃圾话。这是剧本里的一个注释。最后，它说德怀特嘴唇流血了。没人听懂他在说什么。德怀特变得沮丧，跑开了，说，该死，你们这些混蛋。我确实喜欢他尝试开门但门打不开。我也是。我觉得当你想快速离开一个情况却做不到时，这太经典了。是的。好吧，在这个扁带场景之后，托比本来会召开一个关于职场欺凌的会议室会议。它在拍摄草稿里。
It's a really long conference room scene. Everyone attends, and they all share when they felt bullied by Andy. I remember shooting this, Jenna. They are some really hilarious moments. I'm telling you right now you and I broke a few times. It's in the DVD extras. I want to just share a few beats of it. Okay. Okay. Toby starts off the meeting and says, I felt bullied when Andy said he knew why Michael hated me. Pete says, I felt bullied by Andy when he gave me a nickname, I'm not comfortable with. And then Andy says, hey, Andy's a nickname, maybe you're bullying me right now.
这是一个非常长的会议室场景。每个人都参加了，他们都分享了他们什么时候感到被安迪欺凌。我记得拍摄这个，珍娜。有一些非常搞笑的时刻。我现在告诉你，你和我笑场了几次。它在DVD花絮里。我想分享其中的几个节拍。好的。好的。托比开始了会议，说，当安迪说他知道为什么迈克尔讨厌我时，我感到被欺凌了。皮特说，当安迪给我起了一个我不舒服的绰号时，我感到被欺凌了。然后安迪说，嘿，安迪是个绰号，也许你现在正在欺凌我。
And Toby says, Toby's a nickname too. It's short for Tobert. Wow. You're changing the subject. Then Kevin says, Angela bullies me. She won't let me have her cat because I killed my turtle so many times. Everyone starts turning on everyone. Then somehow everyone ends up ganging up on Creed and he leaves the room and the camera
托比说，托比也是个昵称，是托伯特的缩写。哇，你在转移话题。然后凯文说，安吉拉欺负我，她不让我养她的猫，因为我害死了我的乌龟好多次。大家开始互相攻击。然后不知怎么的，大家都开始针对克里德，他离开了房间，摄像机
follows him to that hallway where we all go to have private conversations and Creed starts crying. Oh no! Yeah! Then it comes back to the conference room scene and things get really heated between Phyllis and Angela. You have to hear it. And how can I be a bully?
跟着他去了我们平时去进行私人谈话的走廊，克里德开始哭泣。噢，不！是啊！然后镜头回到会议室，菲利斯和安吉拉之间火药味十足。你一定要听听。我怎么可能是个恶霸？
I'm a sweetie pie. You're a bitch. Oh, God. Oh, my gosh. Angela calls Phyllis a bitch and then Stanley goes, oh no. And Stanley has brought an extra crossword and passes it to Jim. And then Jim leans over to Pam and goes, well, I guess I'm not even the new Jim,
我是个甜心。你是个贱人。天哪。噢，我的天。安吉拉骂菲利斯是贱人，然后斯坦利说，噢，不。斯坦利带了一份额外的填字游戏递给吉姆。然后吉姆凑向帕姆说，好吧，我想我甚至不是新吉姆了，
now I'm the new Stanley. And then Pam goes, well, if you become the new creed, I'll divorce you. Right, his creed is coming back in. And then he starts tearing up again. Oh my gosh, I am remembering this now as you describe it. It was a huge epic conference room scene. Well, instead this episode goes to the warehouse where Dwight is deconstructing a bicycle. I'll have you know that this
现在我是新斯坦利了。然后帕姆说，好吧，如果你变成了新克里德，我就跟你离婚。对，克里德又要回来了。然后他又开始流泪了。噢，我的天，你这么一描述，我全都想起来了。那是一场非常史诗般的会议室戏份。好吧，这一集转到了仓库，德怀特正在拆解一辆自行车。我要告诉你，这
was also meticulously described in the script. There was a whole paragraph describing how he takes this bicycle apart. And it just delighted me because it's very Greg Daniels. I bet Greg literally met with so many people and they had to have precise like drawings and sketches and the physics of it and how it worked. Angela, he made sketches. I'm sure he did. He sent them to me.
在剧本里也有详细的描述。有一整段话描述了他如何拆卸这辆自行车。这让我感到非常高兴，因为这非常有格雷格·丹尼尔斯的风格。我敢打赌格雷格真的和很多人开了会，他们一定有精确的图纸和草图，还有物理原理以及它是如何运作的。安吉拉，他画了草图。我相信他画了。他把草图发给了我。
When we get up on the roof like the whole thing He sketched it out and this is like this is the mad scientist part of Greg's brain and I think Greg would think he could really do this stunt He just needs a counterweight. That's all sure just grab a printer and duct tape it to the bottom of the bicycle No problem. Yeah, but first, I do believe that Greg would ask someone to sit on the bar. I do. We got ahead of ourselves. As you know, Dwight is going to call Pam up onto the roof and reveal what he's doing in the warehouse, and he explains that he is going to ride a bicycle.
当我们上到屋顶时，整件事他都画了出来，这就像是格雷格大脑中疯狂科学家的部分，我想格雷格会认为他真的能完成这个特技。他只需要一个配重。就是这样，当然，只要拿一台打印机用胶带粘在自行车底部就行了。没问题。是啊，但首先，我相信格雷格会让人坐在横梁上。我真的相信。我们有点超前了。如你所知，德怀特要叫帕姆上屋顶，展示他在仓库里做的事情，他解释说他要骑自行车。
I guess from the top of the building to a phone pole, and he wants Pam to be his counterweight, and she refuses. It's a whole thing. Well, I'll have you know on the call sheet for this day. We filmed on August 1st, which is a Wednesday, and the comments on the call sheet were that temperatures were going to exceed 85 degrees. Please stay hydrated.
我想是从楼顶骑到电线杆上，他想让帕姆当他的配重，但她拒绝了。这整件事很复杂。好吧，我要告诉你，在那天的通告单上。我们是在8月1日星期三拍摄的，通告单上的备注是气温将超过85华氏度。请保持水分。
Avoid the sun whenever possible. See the safety bulletin posted by the medic for more information, and that stunt rehearsals and tests for Thursday's aerial work would begin when the company moves to the alley mid afternoon. I see. Yeah. stunt rehearsals.
尽可能避免阳光直射。更多信息请参阅医护人员张贴的安全公告，周四的空中作业特技排练和测试将在下午公司搬到小巷后开始。我明白了。是啊，特技排练。
This was a huge stunt. Well, meanwhile, Angela is interviewing Pete, who doesn't want Comstock yet is going through an extensive interview about his goals in life. Yeah, she says, why do you want this cat? He says, I don't want it. He says, how would you support the cat? What are your ambitions? Pete says, I want to start my own business. I want to be a millionaire. Lots of things. Travel. Make the world a better place. Aren't an NBA at night. Angela says, have you taken any concrete steps Lots of things, travel, make the world a better place. Aren't an NBA at night.
这是一个巨大的特技。好吧，与此同时，安吉拉正在面试皮特，他还不想要康斯托克，但正在经历一场关于他人生目标的详尽面试。是啊，她说，你为什么想要这只猫？他说，我不想要。她说，你打算怎么养这只猫？你有什么抱负？皮特说，我想创业。我想成为百万富翁。很多事情。去旅行。让世界变得更美好。晚上读个MBA。安吉拉说，你采取过任何具体的行动吗？很多事情，去旅行，让世界变得更美好。晚上读个MBA。
Angela says, have you taken any concrete steps? He says, well, I'm still just fitting in here, you know, getting used to the new job. But definitely on the agenda. It's a good idea, Angela. I should make a list. Jim is listening to all of this. It is hitting him hard.
安吉拉说，你采取过任何具体的行动吗？他说，嗯，我还在适应这里，你知道，习惯新工作。但绝对在计划中。这是个好主意，安吉拉。我应该列个清单。吉姆正在听这一切。这对他打击很大。
He has a talking head immediately after where he says, you know what, if he's not careful, he'll get stuck there for years doing nothing. Wow, maybe Pete is the new gym after all. Angela is now gonna explain to Pete that the reason she's getting rid of Comstock is because the baby is allergic. And that Comstock is the Senator's favorite cat.
他紧接着有一个独白，他说，你知道吗，如果他不小心，他会被困在这里几年，什么也做不成。哇，也许皮特真的是新吉姆。安吉拉现在要向皮特解释她要送走康斯托克的原因是因为宝宝过敏。而且康斯托克是参议员最喜欢的猫。
And he's heartbroken. Heartbroken over this. Oh, do Oscars ears perk up? He says, you know what? I will take the cat. Angela is overjoyed. She's like, thank you, Oscar. Yeah, Oscar says I'll come pick him up this evening.
他心碎了。为此心碎。噢，奥斯卡的耳朵竖起来了吗？他说，你知道吗？我会收养这只猫。安吉拉欣喜若狂。她说，谢谢你，奥斯卡。是啊，奥斯卡说我今晚去接它。
And Angela says, oh boy, well, Robert won't get to say goodbye, I guess, because he told me he has plans tonight. Yeah. And Oscar says, say, love you. And Angela says, please don't teach French to my cat. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
安吉拉说，噢，天哪，好吧，我想罗伯特没法跟它道别了，因为他告诉我他今晚有安排。是啊。奥斯卡说，说，爱你。安吉拉说，请不要教我的猫法语。嗯。是啊。
Well then, Oscar's going to sneak away. He's on the phone and guess who he's talking to. His date for the evening, Robert. Yep. phone and guess who he's talking to. His date for the evening, Robert! Yep, he says, you're gonna be able to play with Comp Stock tonight at dinner. Mm-hmm. I have a question. How do we think Gerald is gonna like Comp Stock?
好吧，然后奥斯卡要溜走了。他在打电话，猜猜他在跟谁说话。他今晚的约会对象，罗伯特。没错，他说，你今晚吃晚餐时就能和康斯托克玩了。嗯。我有个问题。我们觉得杰拉德会喜欢康斯托克吗？
I know. There's a whole dog cat introduction that needs to happen here. Yeah, Oscar must really like the senator. A lot. Mm-hmm, because he said he's a dog person. Yeah. Now it's the end of the day and everyone's leaving.
我知道。这里需要进行一整套猫狗介绍流程。是啊，奥斯卡一定非常喜欢参议员。非常喜欢。嗯，因为他说他是爱狗人士。是啊。现在是一天结束了，大家都准备离开。
Jim is gonna linger. He says, I'll meet you down there, Pam. I can barely talk about it. It makes me so upset. Well, I know, I know. I have to say, though, I thought John's performance of Jim in this moment was so great. So good.
吉姆要留下来。他说，我在下面等你，帕姆。我几乎说不出话来。这让我太难过了。好吧，我知道，我知道。但我不得不说，我觉得约翰在这一刻对吉姆的表演太棒了。太好了。
You can see how torn up inside he is about it. He goes to call his friend, then he bails. He's like, no, no, and he gets up and then he goes back and he does it. And when he finally commits and says, I'm all in and hangs up, he's like, yes, it felt so good for him. It's hard. It's hard. I feel obviously like a someone in a relationship.
你可以看出他内心有多纠结。他去给朋友打电话，然后他退缩了。他想，不，不，然后他站起来，又回去做了。当他最终下定决心说，我全心投入并挂断电话时，他想，是的，这让他感觉很好。这很难。这很难。我显然感觉像是一个处于恋爱关系中的人。
I'm like, hey, what are you doing? You got to include your partner in this moment. What are you doing? And then at the same time, I see how much he's struggling with making this decision. I thought it was played out really well. Well, the whole point of this storyline is to create tension in this relationship. Yeah.
我想，嘿，你在做什么？你必须在这一刻把你的伴侣包括进来。你在做什么？与此同时，我看到他在做这个决定时有多挣扎。我觉得这演得非常好。好吧，这条故事线的全部意义在于在他们的关系中制造紧张感。是啊。
And this is going to do it. I wrote in all caps, this is not right. Talk to your wife first. This is a major life decision that affects the entire family. Yes. And when we were talking about this over the summer, I said, this would devastate me. It would devastate me. If my husband and I sat down, we talked about a life decision, we made an agreement. And then without talking to me first, he changed that agreement and took some action. It would devastate me not because he took
这会做到的。我用大写字母写道，这不对。先和你的妻子谈谈。这是一个影响整个家庭的重大人生决定。是的。当我们夏天谈论这件事时，我说，这会摧毁我。这会摧毁我。如果我和我丈夫坐下来，我们谈论了一个人生决定，我们达成了一致。然后在他没有先跟我商量的情况下，他改变了那个协议并采取了一些行动。这会摧毁我，不是因为他采取了
the action, but because he felt like he couldn't trust me enough to talk about it a second time. Well, that's the big thing. That's it right there, which is when you're in a partnership, a partnership is sharing. And the fact that Jim didn't feel like he could share this with his partner, that's the real thing when you pill back the layers. Why couldn't he share this with Pam? Yes, and that would eat away at me as his partner. It would eat away at me to think about,
行动，而是因为他觉得他不够信任我，无法再次谈论这件事。好吧，这就是大事。就是这样，当你处于一段伙伴关系中时，伙伴关系就是分享。事实上，吉姆觉得他不能和他的伴侣分享这件事，当你剥开层层外壳时，这才是真正的问题。为什么他不能和帕姆分享？是的，作为他的伴侣，这会蚕食我。想到这一点会蚕食我，
well then your mind jumps to, well what else do you not feel comfortable sharing with me? Exactly, because I truly believe as Pam, that if Jim came to me and said, I've been thinking about this. And I have to say, I want to do it. And I know it's going to be crazy. And I know it means Philadelphia. Can we make this work for me? The Pam would have said, yes. But he didn't give her the opportunity to support him. He went off on his own and he made a decision. And as we're going to find out in the next episode, keep that decision from her for a long
然后你的思绪会跳到，那你还有什么不觉得舒服跟我分享的？没错，因为作为帕姆，我真心相信，如果吉姆来找我说，我一直在考虑这件事。我不得不说，我想做。我知道这会很疯狂。我知道这意味着费城。我们能为我促成这件事吗？帕姆会说，好的。但他没有给她支持他的机会。他独自行动并做出了决定。正如我们将在下一集中发现的那样，他把这个决定对她隐瞒了很
time. He does not go home tonight and say anything to her for weeks. That's another layer to it. That's the betrayal to me. Yeah. And you know, he sort of alludes to the fact that he didn't want to tell her until it was real. But the minute he said I'm all in, it was real. Yes. And it has the potential to uproot their life in a major way. Yeah. It just, I see the foreshadowing of what is to come. I thought it was brilliantly acted and written because it's doing everything it was supposed to do. Yes. Well, we're now in the parking lot. Dwight has found a counterweight for his bicycle. He calls down to his co-workers. He says,
长时间。他今晚没有回家，几周内什么也没对她说。这是另一层含义。对我来说，那是背叛。是啊。你知道，他暗示他不想在事情成真之前告诉她。但当他说我全心投入的那一刻，它就成真了。是的。它有潜力以重大方式彻底改变他们的生活。是啊。我看到了即将发生的事情的预兆。我觉得表演和剧本都很精彩，因为它完成了它应该做的一切。是的。好吧，我们现在在停车场。德怀特为他的自行车找到了配重。他向下呼喊他的同事。他说，
he's going to show the cool new guys what a real salesman looks like. You only live once and he's going to prove it. Lady, I want you to know in the call sheet for the shoot day, there were an additional five pages of safety bulletins, five pages. I believe it. Of all the different precautions they were taking. Well, Dwight is going to ride the bike along the wire, but when he gets midway, it tips over. He is dangling from the handlebars and has to be rescued by the fire department. We got a fan question from Juan R and Duluth, Georgia, who said, tell us everything about rain cycling stunt
他要向这些酷炫的新人展示真正的推销员是什么样子的。人只活一次，他要证明这一点。女士，我想让你知道，在拍摄当天的通告单上，还有额外的五页安全公告，五页。我相信。关于他们采取的所有不同预防措施。好吧，德怀特要骑着自行车沿着钢丝走，但当他走到一半时，它翻了。他悬在车把上，不得不被消防部门救下。我们收到了来自佐治亚州德卢斯胡安·R的粉丝提问，他说，告诉我们关于雷恩在这集中骑行特技的一切。
in this episode. Well, of course, I reached out to Steve Peress. He's the best. And he said, oh, there's a lot to say about this stunt. He said they started with the rough concept drawings that Greg did. Greg drew it all out, how he imagined it in his head. They brought in Al and Brent Jones, the stunt coordinators, and started discussing how to make it a reality. They brought in Pat Romano to do all the rigging. Steve said we had to put in our own telephone pole.
好吧，当然，我联系了史蒂夫·佩雷斯。他是最棒的。他说，噢，关于这个特技有很多话要说。他说他们从格雷格做的粗略概念图开始。格雷格把它画了出来，他在脑海中想象的样子。他们请来了特技协调员阿尔和布伦特·琼斯，开始讨论如何将其变为现实。他们请来了帕特·罗马诺来做所有的索具。史蒂夫说我们必须安装我们自己的电线杆。
We could not use the real one for safety and legal reasons. Well, yes. So we had to put a second telephone pole up. Let's not tie this to something that has electricity. That's right. We also had to put the giant crane that you mentioned in the parking lot in order to get the wire across the roof. He said that the ends of the wire were attached to huge grade walls, which are like
出于安全和法律原因，我们不能使用真正的电线杆。好吧，是的。所以我们必须竖起第二根电线杆。不要把它系在有电的东西上。没错。我们还必须把你们提到的巨型起重机放在停车场，以便把钢丝穿过屋顶。他说钢丝的两端系在巨大的平地机上，就像
bulldozers because that would really keep it strong, right? He said it took over a week just to do all the rigging and for the stunt they had a giant airbag in the parking lot, and I remember it. I remember it too. It's also in the call sheet. There were multiple pages just describing this airbag. Steve sent us pictures. We'll put it in stories. Steve also mentioned that it was really windy that day. Oh, Lord. And it was actually hard to ride the bike on the wire because of the wind. And so he said we did three takes of the stunt, but it worked. I remember standing
推土机一样，因为那样才能保持强力，对吧？他说光是做所有的索具就花了一周多的时间，为了这个特技，他们在停车场放了一个巨大的气囊，我记得。我也记得。它也在通告单上。光是描述这个气囊就有好几页。史蒂夫给我们发了照片。我们会把它放在故事里。史蒂夫还提到那天风很大。噢，天哪。而且因为风的原因，在钢丝上骑自行车实际上很难。所以他说我们拍了三次特技，但成功了。我记得站在
in the parking lot looking up at the stunt guy. All of us there. I was terrified. I was going to see a death that day. I'm going to be honest with you. I was terrified. It was the most stressful thing. I don't know how anyone works on action movies where they do all of these crazy stunts. It was so terrifying so terrifying Steve Burgess says the shot of rain hanging from the bike is actually rain However, what they did was they built a scaffold rain, however what they did was they built a scaffold under the bike, so rain was actually just about eight or 10 inches above the scaffold. I remember that
停车场抬头看着特技演员。我们所有人在那里。我吓坏了。我那天要目睹一场死亡。老实说。我吓坏了。这是压力最大的事情。我不知道人们是怎么在动作电影里工作的，他们做了所有这些疯狂的特技。太可怕了，太可怕了。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，雷恩挂在自行车上的镜头实际上是雷恩本人。然而，他们做的是他们搭建了一个脚手架
too and that was still scary. I have photos of that as well. We also had to hire a stunt fireman to carry rain stunt double down the fire truck ladder. It is not easy to carry someone down a ladder like that. It was described in the shooting draft that the fireman carried white down like a bride. I like that description. And Steve Burgess said there were many, many, many safety meetings about this and even had to include the NBC safety guy. There were a lot of people who had to sign off on this stunt before we did it. Well, this episode is going to end with Nelly at her desk. She is surrounded by big recycling bins and people are tossing their trash
在自行车下面，所以雷恩实际上只是在脚手架上方大约8或10英寸处。我也记得那个，那还是很吓人。我也有那样的照片。我们还不得不雇佣一名特技消防员把雷恩的替身从消防车梯子上抱下来。像那样抱着人下梯子并不容易。拍摄草稿中描述消防员像抱新娘一样把德怀特抱下来。我喜欢那个描述。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，关于这个有很多很多很多安全会议，甚至不得不包括NBC的安全人员。在我们做这个特技之前，有很多人必须签字批准。好吧，这一集将以内莉坐在她的办公桌前结束。她被巨大的回收箱包围着，人们正在把垃圾扔向
towards her. She's getting hit by the trash. I hated this. I didn't buy it. I didn't think that other people would participate. Same! I didn't think that Phyllis or Stanley would do this. Agree. We get that Andy has a beef with her.
她。她被垃圾击中了。我讨厌这个。我不买账。我不认为其他人会参与。我也是！我不认为菲利斯或斯坦利会这样做。同意。我们明白安迪对她有意见。
I don't think anyone else cares. I'm with you. Andy says he's passionate about two things, recycling and revenge. Now, Nellie's in the conference room doing a talking head, but there's still trash coming at her. She's trying to be positive. She goes, that's a fluke. Well, I don't think we should end on that note.
我不认为其他人会在意。我和你一样。安迪说他热衷于两件事，回收和复仇。现在，内莉在会议室做独白，但垃圾还在向她飞来。她试图保持积极。她说，那是个意外。好吧，我不认为我们应该以那个结尾。
Let's end on an upbeat note, which is, one last, get to know your cast and crew. From a new favorite segment. This one is about Joseph, who was part of our security team. Oh, I remember Joseph. Yes, things you did not know about Joseph Wang. Joseph knows Chinese, Taiwanese, and English. His favorite books are the Harry Potter books.
让我们以一个乐观的基调结束，那就是，最后一次，了解你的演员和工作人员。来自一个新的最爱环节。这个是关于约瑟夫的，他是我们安保团队的一员。噢，我记得约瑟夫。是的，关于约瑟夫·王你不知道的事情。约瑟夫懂中文、台语和英语。他最喜欢的书是哈利·波特系列。
The prettiest place he has ever been is Paris. His favorite superhero is Speedy Gunsallis. His first encounter with the TV film business was Security, of course. And he was once a sports agent and has three tattoos. I love this. And we ran into Joseph because he now does Security for the Kelly Clarkson show. We were so excited. We took pictures. We hugged. Office family forever. Aw, well guys, that was new guys. A big thank you to Greg Daniels and to Steve Burgess for their contributions to this episode.
他去过最漂亮的地方是巴黎。他最喜欢的超级英雄是冈萨雷斯。他第一次接触电视电影行业当然是安保。他曾经是一名体育经纪人，有三个纹身。我喜欢这个。我们遇到了约瑟夫，因为他现在为凯莉·克拉克森秀做安保。我们太兴奋了。我们拍了照片。我们拥抱了。办公室家庭永远。噢，好吧，伙计们，那是新伙计们。非常感谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯和史蒂夫·伯吉斯对这一集的贡献。
Mm-hmm. I think we're off to a good start. I'm excited for this season. Next up is Roy's wedding. Chorwheel. Chorwheel. And I'm sorry, Roy plays the piano now. Oh excuse me! It's so delicious! See you next week! See you then!
嗯。我想我们有一个好的开始。我很期待这一季。接下来是罗伊的婚礼。合唱轮。合唱轮。抱歉，罗伊现在弹钢琴了。噢，打扰一下！太美味了！下周见！到时候见！
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听办公室女士。办公室女士由Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。